MonkaW
Mensch, bin gleich am Start.
So.
Bin am Start.
Ich muss gerade noch die Klimaanlage anmachen.
Hier ist fast 28 Grad drin.
Monk HW.
Moin.
Ja, stream so am Start.
Ich hätte selbst nicht gedacht, dass ich heute Abend noch streame.
Eigentlich,
Moment, ich muss meine Logitech Software starten.
Eigentlich
wollte ich meine
Laufrunde machen heute Abend.
Aber ich habe gesehen, es ist eine super
langweilige, irgendwie
46 Minuten
Grundlagenausdauerrunde
dran. Hab ich mir gedacht, ey komm, scheiß.
Scheiß drauf. Du gehst eh morgen
lange Runde
rennen.
Können wir das heute mal sein lassen und eine Runde streamen.
Gestern hat mir meine Uhr nämlich noch
angezeigt.
Heute wäre
glaube ich
8x40 Sekunden
überlege gerade wie das heißt 8 x 40 sekunden halt halt schneller ziemlich ziemlich zackig
wie o2 max oder sowas workout dran der hat schon bock drauf gehabt aber auf 46 minuten
grundlagen runter es kommt da kann ich heute drauf verzichten deswegen streben eine runde
Ich habe auch eine...
Oh.
Hey, Chef.
So, jetzt muss ich erstmal was trinken.
Echt kaputt, ey.
Obwohl halt auf der Arbeit nicht viel los war,
bin ich trotzdem ziemlich im Arsch.
Ich glaube, ich habe auch zu wenig getrunken
Das merke ich immer, da tut dir der Kopf weh und alles
Ey, Leute, Twitter, Alter
Oh, Mann
Da hatten wir da Leute echt so halben Meltdown am Start
Ist ja Wahnsinn
Ich hab, also, die meisten Tweets jucken mich ja gar nicht großartig.
Bis auf ein paar, ja.
Also gerade Leute, die die WDF nicht gelesen haben und früher geguckt haben
und dann sich genau das falsche Comment rauspicken und so.
Ja, das finde ich ja immer ein bisschen schade.
Aber, aber, ganz ehrlich.
Wenn es eine Sache gibt, die mich auf Twitter richtig krass triggern kann,
ist dieses ganze, ich weiß gar nicht, da gibt es glaube ich sogar ein Wort für,
dieses, ich muss euch jetzt erzählen, wie krass moralischen High Ground ich habe.
Wisst ihr, Leute, die nur antworten, um darauf hinzuweisen,
dass sie sich moralisch richtig krass überlegen fühlen
und das natürlich dann auch ihren anderen Leuten mitteilen müssen.
Guck mal hier, ich bin krass moralisch überlegen.
Gibt es, glaube ich, sogar ein Wort für.
Ey, boah, ey, das ist so, das ist so dumm.
Einfach nur.
Ja, genau so, ich glaube, das ist es.
Ja, genau so was meine ich.
Das ist so der Wahnsinn, Alter.
Das ist so krass, das Circle Jerk da.
Oh, ich habe ja immer noch das Sellout drin.
Das sollte ich mal löschen.
Wann mache ich das gerade mal?
Edit Panels.
Kann man das löschen?
Ist das blöd?
So.
Edit.
Hä?
Hat es das jetzt nicht gespeichert?
Alter.
So kompliziert kann es doch nicht sein.
Remove?
safe
okay ich sehe ich sehe ihr habt das ihr habt das teilweise verfolgt
ich hab da noch vieles gar nicht zwar mehr teilweise ich war ich war ja
normalerweise kein leute wisst ihr ganz gerne
er ist heute auf
kehrmann richtigen satzform
es ist ja ich ich antworte teilweise auch ganz gerne drauf aber das wird mir
dann mit der zeit einfach zu viel
und vor allem sind sich selbst so dieses typische
Schaut her, wie moralisch erhaben ich bin.
Und wichtig, dass das alle sehen.
Boah, das ist so dumm, Alter.
Aber das gibt es überall.
Das gibt es überall mittlerweile.
So diesen sich selbst aufs Podest stellen und zeigen,
oh, schaut her, ich habe hier den moralischen High Ground.
Richtig nervig
So
Chatge
Dann machen wir mal
Die VM an und dann zeige ich euch
Was wir heute vorhaben
Wobei eigentlich muss ich das gar nicht zeigen
Weil die Leute die im letzten Stream dabei waren
Die wissen das wahrscheinlich
Wir machen heute das hier
Das da.
Python self-contained binary ohne
Abhängigkeiten
zu irgendwas.
Ja, weil
ich habe doch letztens auf Twitter
geschrieben. Nein, nein, nein. Nicht das.
Ich habe doch
letztens auf Twitter geschrieben,
dass ich gerne
mehr Python verwenden würde
für CLI-Tools.
Moment.
Alter, sag mal, kann das sein?
War eine blöde Frage.
Kann das sein, dass man
ohne eingeloggt zu sein
auf Twitter keine Links
mehr rauskopieren kann?
Das ist ja unglaublich hängen geblieben
Also Twitter ist auch
Ex-formally known as Twitter
Ist auch nicht wirklich
Besser geworden
Die letzten Jahre
Okay, okay, hier. Den Tweet meine ich.
Nitter.
Benutze ich auch öfters.
Den Tweet hier meine ich.
Und zwar...
What the fuck, Alter?
Was ist das?
Kann das nicht mal
verpissen hier, please?
Für Apps
scannen. Okay, also.
Eigentlich ging es um diesen Tweet.
Der ist entstanden dadurch, dass wir da letztens im Stream drüber diskutiert haben.
Und zwar, ich würde ja gerne öfters Python für CLI-Tools benutzen,
aber das Packaging von Apps als Self-Contained Binary ist richtig krasser Paintschamp.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Das ist sowohl nutzermäßig runtergekommen, als auch Usability-mäßig.
So, und nachdem wir das letzte Mal im Stream drüber geredet haben und der Chat damals gesagt hat,
oh ja, das wäre mal ein nice Stream-Thema, dass ich mal versuche eine Python-Anwendung als Self-Contained Binary zu bauen,
das auf möglichst vielen Linux-Distributionen läuft, habe ich mir gedacht, probieren wir das heute mal aus.
ich hab mir
im Vorfeld
machen wir mal kurz hier noch ein zweites Notepad auf
ich hab mir im Vorfeld
schon ein paar Sachen
überlegt
beziehungsweise ich hab schon mal ein bisschen auf GitHub gesucht
Und das sind so die Lösungen, die ich gefunden habe, wie man mit Python mehr oder weniger gut oder unabhängig oder wie auch immer Self-Contained Apps bauen kann.
Also es gibt wohl einmal was, das nennt sich PyOxidizer. Das soll dafür wohl richtig gut geeignet sein. Das Problem ist, ich zeige euch die Projekte auch gleich, das Problem ist wohl, das Hauptprojekt ist nicht mehr maintained.
Da gibt es aber einen Fork, der aber auch nur ganz lightweight maintained wird.
Dann gibt es wohl Cosmolibc, einen Python-Interpreter, der ist komplett, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die das gemacht haben,
Der ist komplett self-contained und ein einzelnes Binary, was läuft auf Windows, Linux und BSD.
Das ist richtig krasser Scheiß, keine Ahnung, wie der das gemacht hat.
Und vielleicht kann man damit Python-Apps statisch compilen.
Das müssen wir mal schauen.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, nicht so gut für umfangreiche Python-Programme,
weil das keinerlei Dependencies unterstützt.
Also sobald du irgendwelche Module verwenden willst, geht das wohl nicht.
Dann gibt es irgendwie hier so einen neuen Python-Compiler.
Da habe ich nur zufällig das Projekt gesehen, keine Ahnung, ob das was kann.
Dann habe ich irgendwo gelesen, da hat einer mit NU-NU-TK und einem Alpine-Linux.
wohl statische Apps gebaut.
Das ist wohl ein Python2C
Compiler, der dann
statische Binaries irgendwie raushauen
kann. Da müssen wir mal gucken.
Dann habe ich noch gelesen,
dass es Leute gibt, die
Pi-App verwenden.
In Kombination mit
ManyLinux.
Was auch immer genau ManyLinux
ist. Das muss wohl irgendein
Binary-Format für Python-
Anwendungen sein. Irgendwie was in der
Richtung. So, dann gibt es wohl noch den Klassiker
Pi-Installer.
So, und ich würde sagen, das probieren wir jetzt halt mal so von unten nach oben
oder so aus. Oder gucken uns das mal an.
Vielleicht fallen ja schon manche Sachen
direkt raus, wo wir sagen, es ist komplett sinnlos.
Müssen wir nicht verwenden.
So, jetzt machen wir erst einmal den
Mini-PC an.
Deskflow.
Du hast bestimmt auch
auf dieses Issue gestoßen.
Weiß ich nicht. Gucken wir gleich.
Chat, ich weiß, nicht die beste Zeit
zum Streamen jetzt.
Freitag 17.30 Uhr.
Viele sind noch auf der Arbeit, auf dem Weg von der Arbeit.
Machen noch Einkäufe fürs Wochenende.
Aber ich hab mir gedacht, wisst ihr was?
Wenn das ein größeres Thema wird, streamen wir heute und morgen.
Das gleiche Thema.
Und wenn es schnell erledigt ist,
können wir morgen was anderes machen.
Irgendwie hab ich jetzt Bock,
mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Perfekte Zeit.
Ja, für die meisten glaube ich, ist es nicht so günstig.
Aber es gibt ja immer noch Worts.
Das ist das Just make a fucking exe-file-and-give-it-to-me-Issue.
Das kenne ich nicht.
Das muss ich mir jetzt angucken.
Ne, das kenne ich nicht.
Ich gucke es mir gleich an.
So, und ich brauche dann von den Python-Kennern unter euch...
Chat, haben wir Leute, die öfters Python machen?
Also mehr als ich.
Weil ich mache so gut wie gar nicht.
Haben wir ein paar, die ein bisschen Plan haben wenigstens.
So minimal.
So, gibt es Leute, die aus dem Kopf ein Python Hello World hinbekommen, was, äh, keine Ahnung, NumPy verwendet?
Frag mich nicht, was das miteinander zu tun hat, aber, weil ich wüsste weder, wie ich NumPy verwende, ich weiß nur, ganz viele Leute verwenden das,
noch wüsste ich aus dem Kopf tatsächlich, wie man Hello World macht.
Ich glaube, Printf, nee, Println, Print, nee, einfach nur Print, gell?
In Python ist es, glaube ich, nur Print. Einfach nur Print.
Einfach nur Print Hello World.
Aber ImportSys. ImportSys muss man machen, gell?
ImportSys oder, ja, oder OS. Nee, ImportSys muss man machen.
ImportSys Print Hello World. Ich glaube, sowieso geht das.
Nee, musst du nicht. Einfach so ist Print Standard Library ohne Import.
Okay, das ist doch mal das Video.
Also, ihr habt zumindest schon mal mehr Planen wie ich.
Wir brauchen eine kleine Testanwendung.
Am liebsten hätte ich natürlich auch eine, die irgendein Python-Modul verwenden.
Weiß nicht, was sich da am besten anbietet.
NumPy oder so.
Ich bin da wirklich recht planlos, was das angeht.
Das letzte Mal, wo ich in Python was programmiert habe,
haben wir, glaube ich, sogar im Stream gemacht,
ist, wo ich, als ich noch i3 verwendet habe,
da habe ich mir hier oben noch so einen Timer für die Taskleiste programmiert.
Und
Der ist in Python gewesen
Das ist glaube ich das letzte Mal wo ich in Python was gemacht habe
Sinnvoll
Also
Das ist das Issue
Zeig mal her
Just make a fucking exe file
And give it to me
I don't give a fuck about the code
I just want to download a stupid
Fucking application and use it
Das kann ich nicht
kenne ich tatsächlich nicht.
Für CLI-Tools kannst du
Click verwenden. Click kenne ich.
Click ist so ein Command-Line-Parser,
gell? Das ist quasi das,
das Clap, ich glaube
Clap heißt es in Rust und ich glaube
Clap ist einer, der sich von Click
hat inspirieren lassen.
Aber mir geht es nicht so sehr darum, eine CLI-App
zu bauen. Ich, Moment, ich schreibe
nochmal in den Titel des Streams CLI-App
für
CLI App
für CLI App
self
komplett self contained
Schreiben wir den Titel so.
so eine f pro kramer dass das das muss man aber wie gesagt ich glaube klick ist ja der
command line pass und ein tool um seine anwendung zu packen oder fragezeichen oder
klick
welcome package for creating beautiful command line fs ach ja das ist das nächste das machen
wir in python gibt es auch rich das ist doch so eine library wurde wo du schön command line also
text output machen kannst die binden wir ein da haben wir gleich schon import und können gucken
ob wir unsere App damit gebaut bekommen.
Genau.
Wie gesagt, ich bin, was Python
angeht, ich kann das lesen,
ich kann da drin auch was programmieren, aber ich mach
das in so großen Abständen, dass ich immer
jedes Mal, wenn ich wieder neu damit anfange, komplett
planlos bin.
So, eine Runde AskIquarium,
um sich darauf einzustimmen.
Noch was trinken.
Hey, F-Programmer, wie geht's?
Du bist ja auch immer am Start,
in letzter Zeit.
KI kann die Anwendung bauen.
Es ist schön, wenn KI das kann.
Aber es geht ja darum, dass ich das kann.
Moin.
Du reparierst gerade eine Espressomaschine.
Da bin ich raus.
Ich trinke keinen Kaffee.
wobei reparieren macht bestimmt auch bock wenn man so gerne bastelt an solchen
dingern aber trinken würde ich nicht ich bin kein kaffeetrinker das ist
eigentlich doppelt merkwürdig ich es ist eigentlich doppelt ich müsste eigentlich
aus zwei gründen kaffee komplett weg hauen weg kippen wie nix
ich bin fahrradfahrer und ich bin informatiker und beide hauen sich
normalerweise kaffee bis zum umkippen rein
wie willst du das machen kieselweich das ist ja genau das thema des streams wir
gucken mal was sich dafür anbietet ich habe im vorfeld ein bisschen geguckt
auf github was es so gibt und anscheinend sind das hier so die oder
Es sind so sechs mögliche Varianten, die ich gefunden habe.
Wir fangen jetzt einfach mal von unten nach oben an.
Wir fangen mal mit Pi Installer an, weil das wohl am einfachsten ist.
Da habe ich aber schon einige Sachen gesehen, warum Pi Installer nicht unbedingt das Beste ist.
Ich glaube, ich habe schon direkt auf den ersten Blick Probleme bei Pi Installer gesehen.
Nicht sicher, ob das auch von Dein ist.
Zeig mal her.
Ja, das ist der Pie-Oxidizer-Typ, glaube ich.
Ach, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ja, das ist der Pie-Oxidizer-Typ.
Das habe ich hier auch drin stehen.
Das ist der, das ist das hier.
Aber das hier ist nicht, um Apps selbst zu bauen.
Das ist um...
Ja, das ist das hier.
Ja, das habe ich bei mir auch schon drin stehen.
Das ist aber nicht, um Self-Contained-Anwendungen zu bauen.
Das ist ein Self-Contained-Python-Interpreter.
Das ist wieder was anderes.
In Kombination ist das praktisch.
Aber der Typ hat auch PyOxidizer gemacht,
mit dem man auch wohl Self-Contained-Python-Anwendungen bauen kann.
Das Problem daran ist,
deswegen habe ich mir das hier das letzte Mal aufgeschrieben,
das Problem daran ist,
das Projekt ist nicht mehr maintained.
Und...
Es gibt da wohl einen Fork, der aber auch relativ, naja, sehr selten mal maintained wird.
Max, mir wurde verboten, deine Streams anzuschauen.
Oh, Sätge.
Da kann man wohl nichts machen.
Ja, unmaintained ist so eine Sache, weil
das Ding ist, dass gerade bei Python
kommt ja immer wieder mal neue Versionen raus
Oh, guck mal, das letzte Release 4 years ago
Wer hatte denn verboten, meine Streams anzuschauen?
Ich erlaub dir einfach wieder meine Streams anzuschauen
Easy
Dann ist die Sache erledigt
Dann steht Aussage gegen Aussage
Die Streams sind zu pfeifert
Deine bessere Hälfte
Naja, komm, jetzt mal
So für, versöhnlich mal
Man muss ja nicht unbedingt die ganze Wohnung
Mit irgendwelchen Random-Streams beschallen
Vor allem, was die andere Leute null juckt
Zieh dir einfach Kopfhörer auf
Und gut, das ist ein Guck auf dem Handy
Mir geht das auch übelst auf den Sack, wenn hier Leute teilweise auf dem Fernseher, ja auf dem Fernseher auch, aber auf dem Tablet beispielsweise sich irgendwelche Dinge angucken, die ich normalerweise nicht mal, weiß nicht, nicht mal besoffen mir angucken würde.
Schlechter Einfluss, wieso?
Zu High IQ oder wie?
Zu Pfeifett?
zu pfeifen content
So
Also dann fangen wir doch mal dann fangen wir doch mal kurz von von unten nach oben an also das erste projekt was nicht
Moment mal erst einmal brauchen wir irgend so eine peisen anwendung
Da machen wir jetzt mal hier repos
mk dir habe ich eigentlich einen template für
Also, nee, hab ich nicht.
Na gut. Wir müssen das auch nicht in einem Container
entwickeln. Wir downloaden
ja keine großartigen Abhängigkeiten und sonst was.
Haben wir hier MKDeer.
MKDeer Self-Contained
Champ. Okay.
Aber mal eine Frage.
Hier, irgendjemand hat das doch gerade im
Chat gepostet.
Der Kieselweich war das, glaube ich.
Bist du öfters
Python-Hackerman?
Also, machst du öfters was damit?
Und wenn ja, was ist das hauptsächlich, was du damit machst?
Weil ich glaube, für einen Großteil der Anwendung ist das mit Self-Contained-Anwendungen gar nicht so wichtig.
Wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwelche Business-Dinger baust, irgendwelche Web-Backends oder sowas,
die kommen in Container-Image rein und dann wird das Container-Image gestartet und gut, da hast du alles dabei.
Dann ist das nicht so wirklich wild.
Wenn du allerdings CLI-Tools, und da geht es mir ja drum, ich würde gerne noch neben Go und teilweise ein bisschen C-Sharp, C-Sharp ist mit IoT auch gar nicht schlecht, was das angeht mittlerweile, aber Go ist der King, was Self-Contained Applications angeht.
Ich zeige euch das gerade nochmal.
Bevor wir anfangen, ich zeige euch das mal in Go.
Go ist das, was zu schlagen gilt.
Was ich aber glaube, was wir mit keiner
Python-Sache schaffen.
Ja, bei Rust
ist es gut.
Rust kannst du ja einfach mit
static
muselip
target kompilieren und du hast
ein self-contained binary, was einfach überall läuft.
Es sei denn, du hast
halt irgendwelche externen Abhängigkeiten.
Ja, bei Rust ist das deutlich einfacher.
aber für CLI-Anwendungen ist das halt mega praktisch, ja, und ich zeige euch mal kurz, wie das in Go geht, okay,
haben wir noch hier irgendwo eine PW-Champ, was ist der PW-Champ nochmal gewesen, ist das eine Go-Anwendung?
Okay
App
Hier, guck mal hier, PwChamp
Da ist
Go ist vor allem mit Whales
Whales habe ich noch nie benutzt
Also in Go ist es folgendermaßen
Äh, warte mal, C, Go, Enable
Das hier muss man machen
Hier
Also, CGO enabled, gleich 0, Go build, ich hoffe ich mache das jetzt richtig, Go build, Punkt, bam.
Und jetzt, baut er die Anwendung, okay.
Sauert jetzt initial mal kurz.
So, und jetzt haben wir hier eine LDD-App.
Jetzt haben wir hier eine Self-Contained-Anwendung, die, zeig's euch App, Listening on Port 8080.
Was zum Teufel habe ich hier überhaupt gemacht?
Warum listet da irgendwas on-port?
Was ist das eigentlich?
Ich kann mich überhaupt nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Chat, ich bin legit planlos, was ich hier gebaut habe.
Ach, ich weiß es wieder.
Die Webseite, wo man den Passwort-Safe hochladen konnte und es dann downloaden kann.
Ah, ja, okay.
Also, seht ihr?
Es ist jetzt egal, ob das jetzt eine CLI-Anwendung ist oder ein Webpackend.
Ist wurscht.
Aber ich habe das...
Genau, das war ein Portierungstool.
Also, ich habe das hier...
Wir können das auch nochmal anders machen.
Main.go.
Wo ist hier Main?
Main.
Machen wir einfach hier...
Es kann sein, dass Go jetzt meckert, wenn man das hier...
mit nicht nicht verwendet.
Pogu.
Ey, Go fuckt mich mit solchen Sachen
schon teilweise richtig ab.
Okay, so.
Jetzt haben wir das hier kompiliert.
Guck mal, wir haben eine Go, also das ist,
darum geht's. So was will ich mit Python eventuell.
Also das ist das, was es zu schlagen gilt.
Ja.
So, wir haben jetzt eine Go-Anwendung kompiliert und die Go-Anwendung ist komplett self-contained.
Die läuft überall und ich kann euch das auch beweisen, dass die überall läuft.
Wir machen jetzt mal zum Beispiel hier docker run, machen wir mal debian 13, dann haben wir hier minus v pwd na slash data.
debian 13 slash data ausführen app läuft.
Und jetzt passt mal auf.
Jetzt passt mal auf, wie nice
das ist.
Wir machen jetzt mal Debian 8,
falls es das noch gibt.
CD, Data, Debian 8. Also das ist
wirklich alt, ja.
Data
App läuft.
Ja.
Ubuntu
1204.
Können wir uns darauf einigen, dass Ubuntu
1204 fucking old ist?
Das ist vom April 2012.
Das ist 14 Jahre alt.
Ubuntu 12.04.
Wir gehen hier rein.
Nein, selbst Alpine funktioniert.
App, bam, läuft.
Das ist halt wirklich eines der besten Gründe für Go, wenn man sowas machen will.
Nee, nee, Alpine geht auch.
Guck, Alpine, was ist denn bei Alpine?
Okay, Mama, hier ist egal.
Alpine Latest.
Ich glaube, SH, oder?
Moin, Sarix.
Data slash App.
Bam, läuft.
Ja, das ist ja gerade das Gute an Go.
Go braucht keine C-Library.
Und Go linkt auch nicht gegen irgendeine C-Library.
Die haben das alles komplett selber implementiert.
Die haben keinerlei Abhängigkeiten, außer zu dem Linux-Kernel-Interface für Calls zum Linux-Kernel hin.
Und was die benutzen, die sind halt stable seit 2.6.32-Kernel.
Also Go-Anwendungen laufen auf jedem Linux.
Egal ob Musel.libc, Knugelibc oder irgendeine andere libc-Library.
Go-Libraries laufen überall.
Die haben keine Abhängigkeit zu irgendeiner C-Library.
Die haben das alles selbst implementiert.
Und das ist halt richtig geil.
Go läuft einfach überall.
Scheißegal wo.
Ja, das ist so.
So, und das gilt es zu schlagen.
Also meinem Kenntnisstand nach gibt es, was Self-Contained Apps angeht, nichts, was irgendwie an Go rankommt.
Deswegen ist Go mein Go-To.
Okay, das war jetzt bescheuerter Satz, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Deswegen ist Go immer das Mittel der Wahl bei mir für CLI-Anwendungen mittlerweile.
Wenn ich irgendwelche kleinen Tools als CLI-Anwendungen bauen will, dann mache ich das in Go.
Weil das kannst du kompilieren
Auf deinem System
Und
Irgendeinem Typ
Der auf der Welt schicken
Der braucht nur einen Linux, bam es läuft
Ja, und wisst ihr
Übrigens was auch geil ist an Go
Kann ich euch an der Stelle auch nochmal zeigen
Cross-Kompilieren, ich weiß wir sind jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
Wir sind jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
Ein bisschen
Sidetracked
Aber ich zeige euch das auch nochmal
Man kann, da bin ich mir jetzt allerdings gar nicht mehr sicher.
Go Arch ist es, glaube ich.
Windows.
Nee, Go OS.
Go OS.
Guck mal, ich kann Go OS.
Go OS gleich Windows sagen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das so richtig ist.
Go OS gleich Windows.
Und jetzt.
App.
Äh, oder auch nicht.
ok.exe und jetzt habe ich eine windows anwendung also ist mega geil für self
content anwendungen und für wir müssen da schnell cross compile von linux zu
windows also was was was portabilität und und packaging angeht es gibt ich
kenne zumindest nichts besseres als gogo ist wirklich der der pock champ was das
angeht. Ja, Go, es sind auch
Sachen, es sind nicht alles geil bei Go.
Es gibt genug Sachen, die nicht geil sind bei Go.
Ja, zum Beispiel, dass du keine Arrays
filtern kannst, sondern Schleifen machen musst und solche
Dinger. Ist alles nicht so geil.
Aber was
Portabilität angeht und
dieses Cross-Compile-Dinger, das ist der
Wahnsinn in Go. Das ist wirklich das Beste, was es
gibt. Und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir das in irgendeiner
Art und Weise, wenn auch nur annähernd
so gut in Python hinkriegen. Weil ich würde
schon ganz gern ab und zu mal
Python-Anwendungen machen.
weil ich die sprache mehr lernen will und weil ich glaube für so für so
schnell schnell was erstellen ist ist peinlich sogar noch ein ticken besser
als go und ich glaube es gibt auch deutlich mehr leute die passen können
als go wobei go an sich eigentlich auch eine recht easy sprache ist
Go is goated, was das angeht.
Ja.
Self-Contained Champ.
Gut, legen wir mal eine App an.
Komm, Wim.
Main.py, okay?
So.
Okay, Chat.
Irgendjemand hat doch vorhin was gepostet,
was man gut als Beispiel nehmen kann, oder?
Hat doch irgendjemand einen Namen?
Hier, guck mal, der Finn hat was gepostet.
Angeblich.
Moment, hast du das...
Hast du das...
Ist das...
Vibe-Coded, Finn?
MyString?
Array?
Okay.
Chat, chat, funzt das so?
Python main.
Der sagt, ich habe NumPy nicht installiert.
Oh, ich habe NumPy installiert.
Okay, es funktioniert.
Okay, das nehmen wir als Beispiel.
Weil, das ist insofern...
Und jetzt machen wir noch mit rich...
Moment.
Rich Python Color Console.
Das machen wir jetzt da noch.
Das Vergleich sehen, dass der auch irgendwie was bundlen kann und sowas.
Rich Python.
Mal gucken, ob ich das überhaupt installiert habe.
Ja, habe ich installiert.
Example.
You can import.
Ah.
From rich import.
Das finde ich ja cool.
From rich import print.
Und dann kannst du hier so sagen
Hello, Bolt, Magenta,
World, Vampire, Locals
Okay, was kommt da jetzt raus
Wenn es fertig ist
Excellent
Hast du schon mal die Go-Link probiert?
Das macht es einfacher
Was ich ganz nice finde ist
das da.
Das ist auch so ähnlich.
Weil das letzte Mal, als ich mir
GoLink und solche Libraries angeguckt
habe, hatten die alle noch kein Generic
Support. Und das hier ist wohl mit Generic
Support.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice.
Guck mal, 21.000 Sterne.
Und das kann auch so Sachen hier.
Guck, Filter und
Filter, Map.
Ja, das
finde ich nice.
So, Locals machen wir mal weg.
Und da kommt jetzt
myStringArray.
So, sehr schön.
Da haben wir unser Testprogramm.
Gut, dann fangen wir mal an.
Also, das Einfachste ist wohl
PyInstaller.
Schauen wir uns mal an. GitHub Pi Installer.
Schauen wir uns mal an, wie das funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, außer dass ich im Vorfeld ein bisschen
geguckt habe, was es da für Projekte gibt, kein
blassen Schimmer.
Freeze Python Programs into
Standalone Executables.
Pi Installer, how it
works.
Also lesen wir mal.
What Pi Installer
does and how it does it.
Lest Python-Skripte, analysiert jedes Modul, das die Bibliothek benötigt.
Ja, das ist gut.
Dann sammelt, kopiert all diese File,
inklusive eines aktivierten Python-Interpreters
und stellt sie mit einem Skriptfall oder einer Einzeloption.
Wie war der One-Folder-Welt?
Bundling zu einem File.
Ja, das will ich. Das will ich haben.
One file.
PyInstaller can bundle your script
and all its dependencies in a single
executable. Genau das will ich machen.
Ich meine, vielleicht ist es ja auch
tatsächlich schon das erste Programm, was das wunderbar kann.
Aber soweit ich das
bisher gesehen habe in Python, ist das
echt schwierig.
The adventure is...
Warum ist das slower?
Uploader ist ja unstartig.
Ah, it creates a temporary folder in the appropriate temp folder location.
Ja, das finde ich schon mal doof.
Das finde ich schon mal doof.
Also, ich meine, das ist was, was ich in Kauf nehmen würde.
Dass es irgendwo temp-Files anlegt und von da das startet.
also im Prinzip ist das so eine Art
Self-Extracting Zip-File, wenn man
so will.
Das bundelt das, entpackt das irgendwo hin
und entpackt
auch den Interpreter und startet das dann in dem
Ordner. Aber das erzeugt
Temp-Files auf dem
jeweiligen
OS
was vielleicht je nach
Berechtigung Probleme geben könnte, keine Ahnung.
Und ist auch lahm.
Aber wir probieren das trotzdem mal aus.
Also, Pi-Installer.
Ich brauche jetzt...
Wann kommt der Rust-Rewrite?
Das ist doch im Trend,
die Rust-Rewrites sich jetzt von Cloud-Code machen zu lassen.
So wie BAM.
So, gibt es da
Using Pi Installer
Pi Installer MyScript
Okay
Ich müsste
Ich müsste das erstmal installieren
Wie installiert man das überhaupt
Install
How to install Pi Installer
Pip install Pi Installer
Bam, wie, hab ich nicht drauf
ETF
Pip
Wobei, die coolen Leute
verwenden doch gar nicht mehr Pip, oder?
Ist es nicht so, dass die coolen Leute mittlerweile
UV verwenden?
Hab ich das nicht mal...
Python-Chat-Gist.
UV oder Pip?
Ja, UV.
UV.
Okay.
UV. Wir nehmen UV.
Und wie installt man da jetzt was?
UV-Install einfach, oder wie?
Gibt es sowas wie UV-Run?
Ja, gibt es.
Äh, UV-Init?
Was?
Warum habe ich da jetzt
einen Project-Tommel?
Äh.
What?
Okay, jetzt bin ich ein wenig per.
UV Install.
Pi Installer.
Geht's es?
UV.
Pip Install.
Was?
Äh.
wie viel funktioniert das jetzt install habe ich doch gemacht
macht
Ja cargo wäre nice
No, no and virtual environment von
Vf2 creator environment or pass minus wie wir erstellen ein environment
Wir erstellen mal wir erstellen wir erstellen mal ein environment
Bin ich da jetzt schon drin?
Okay, nice
Okay, P-Installer
Ah, jetzt haben wir es
Okay, also wie funktioniert das jetzt?
Pi-Installer und dann einfach sagen
Main Pi
Und nun?
Wo ist es jetzt unter?
unter Dist oder unter
Build. Main.
Ah, das ist der ganze Ordner.
Ne, ich will ja,
ich will ja, äh, OneFile
oder so hieß das, gell?
Yes.
Results are in self-contained
Dist.
Main. Okay.
So, jetzt kommt der Moment, da
Wahrheit, warum PyInstaller wahrscheinlich
nicht so geil ist.
Genau.
Linked gegen
System LibC.
Das ist damit
schon mal nicht zu gebrauchen.
Also, was heißt nicht zu gebrauchen? Das Problem ist, dass
wir das jetzt gegen ein ganz altes
bilden müssen,
damit das überhaupt funktioniert.
Ja, das ist in der Tat schon
ein bisschen eklig.
Also das Problem ist jetzt, ich kann es euch mal zeigen.
Wenn ich das jetzt hier nehme.
Wenn ich das hier jetzt nehme.
Wir nehmen mal wieder meinen Ubuntu, okay?
Wir nehmen mal wieder meinen Ubuntu 12.04, weil da habt ihr es vorhin mit der Go-Anwendung gesehen.
Da gehen wir jetzt nach Slash Data.
Dist.
Und jetzt führe ich es aus.
Main.
Bäm, geht nicht, weil Gleap C ist not found.
Also die GLEP-C-Version, gegen die das dynamisch linkt, ist hier auf dem Ubuntu viel, viel, viel zu alt, weil es gegen meine neue GLEP-C gelinkt ist.
Also das funktioniert schon immer nett.
Chatkiss.
Das funktioniert so nicht.
Was wahrscheinlich funktionieren würde, ist...
Bin ich jetzt in diesem V-Env drin?
Ja.
uvpip install
Wir machen jetzt mal sowas hier.
ähm
Ja, aber das ist
das ist richtig dumm.
Das ist richtig dumm.
Also es gibt
eine Möglichkeit, das zu umgehen.
Man kann jetzt einfach in einem ganz alten
Linux, ja zum Beispiel
in einem Ubuntu 12.04 oder so,
kann man das jetzt bauen.
Das Ding ist nur,
klick mal ein aktuelles Python
und die Packages und alles
unter einem Ubuntu 12.04 zum Laufen.
Also, du musst auf jeden Fall
vom Source kompilieren. Ich glaube nicht, dass es
da was gibt.
Wobei, das können wir machen. Wir können...
Wir können das mal probieren.
Vielleicht ist Pi-Installer doch ganz brauchbar.
Wartet mal, ich habe eine Idee.
Ich habe doch hier ManyLinux.
ManyLinux gibt es doch auch als Docker-Image oder sowas.
Dass wir das vielleicht mit einem Docker-Image machen?
Wie würdet ihr das machen?
Guck mal hier, es gibt ManyLinux 1, ManyLinux 2010.
Docker-File.
Ach da, da ist doch hier.
Ja.
Many Linux X6...
Äh, QI, das ist Red Hat, oder?
Ist das nicht Red Hat Registry?
QI.
Doch, ist es.
ja okay hier locker fall wir machen mal locker ran
lasst uns mal den kram hier so starten und dann mal gucken was man damit
überhaupt machen kann
jetzt muss ich erstmal stocker fall runterladen das dauert
Hallo?
Okay, Slash Data.
Qui wird tatsächlich Key ausgesprochen.
What?
Okay, Redhead.
Redhead macht Redhead-Dinger.
Ist denn Pip hier jetzt drauf?
PipX ist drauf.
Gibt es denn jetzt Python in irgendeiner Form?
Okay.
Python 3.
10 gibt es da nur.
Das ist aber nicht so aktuell, oder?
Ist nicht 3...
Ist nicht 3.13 oder so?
Aktuell?
Nee, 3.15 glaubst du gar.
Ach, Opt.
Opt.
Hä?
Ach, es gibt ein System Python und ein...
...ein 10.
Gibt es da nicht irgendwas aktuelleres?
CP?
3, ja, machen wir halt mal 13.
Also das ist schon mal halt eklig.
314 ist das aktuelle, okay.
Wen gibt's da? Pip?
Pip?
Ah ja.
Okay, dann...
Dann probieren wir das mal aus.
Aber da sieht man schon, dass es ein richtiger Akt ist,
da zu bilden.
Also, Opt, Python,
CP, 310.
Gibt es hier vielleicht noch
was Aktuelleres, wo wir gerade
dabei sind?
Oh, 4 years ago.
Oh.
Was ist, wenn ich das weglasse?
Nix.
Was ist, wenn ich
Many Linux 1 hinschreibe? Auch nicht.
Äh.
Wo sehe ich denn, was ist in dieser
Oh, diese
Red Hat Registry, die ist so dumm, Alter.
Boah, mein Auge.
Leute, ich sehe nichts mehr.
Boah.
Close.
Close call.
Kann man hier vielleicht
drinnen suchen?
Oh, diese Redhead Registrier.
Weil es ist so...
Ah!
Ein Chat hier vielleicht.
Kann ich hier nach Many Linux suchen?
Ah ja, tatsächlich.
Many Linux.
14.
Können wir so nach 2010 suchen, mal.
Okay, Many Linux 2010 ist 4 years ago.
2014 war irgendwie aktueller, oder?
2 days ago.
Okay.
Ja, dann.
Dann gebe ich ihm.
Dann das hier. Easy.
Next.
Bam.
Was wir hier wieder für
gefuddelt brauchen. Ey, wisst ihr, wie das funktioniert?
Da haben wir bestimmt auch ein bisschen was
aktuelleres jetzt drauf.
Kann man
UV eigentlich auch mit Pip installen?
Pip install UV.
Upp.
anna uv irgendwelche sachen können ok ggx gibt es auch so wie us ok ok ok also ob
Python. Ach, guck mal.
Da gibt es 3,
14. Bin,
pip,
install uv. Brauchen wir
das überhaupt? Ne, brauchen wir gar nicht.
Brauchen wir gar nicht uv. Brauchen wir überhaupt nicht.
Wir wollen jetzt einfach pip
install
numpy
und bridge.
Ja.
Ah, NumPy.
Oh, das ist ja noch ekliger.
NumPy kann ja nicht installiert werden, weil es C-Module braucht.
Monka WXD HD.
Alter.
Ähm, das heißt, ich muss jetzt...
Ist das ein YAM?
Install.
Build Essentials.
Oder war das Debian?
Base Devil heißt es.
Ne.
Oh Gott.
War das Base Devil bei Red Hat?
Warum nennt dieser Kram dieses Build Essential vielleicht so?
Okay.
YUM Install Build Essentials.
Warum nennen diese Packages hier mal jede Distribution anders?
Vielleicht muss ich auch vorhin ein YUM Update einfach machen.
Geht nicht.
Group Install Development Tools.
Okay.
Nice.
GG, Red Hat.
GL. Habt ihr gut gemacht.
Das ist natürlich auch
viel logischer
als, naja, wobei, mal ganz
im Ernst, wenn man sich da dran gewöhnt,
Development Tools
ist schon irgendwie
ein bisschen, aber ich finde trotzdem Install Build
Essentials und Base Develop und sowas
besser.
Also der Workflow, so
gefällt mir schon mal gar nicht, aber wir probieren
es trotzdem mal aus.
So, und jetzt
Pip, Pip install NumPy
Unrich
Okay, NumPy
NumPy requires GCC
größer, ja geil
Ja geil
Okay
Also ist schon mal nicht möglich
damit ältere Sachen
zu kompilieren
gescheit
Wir könnten noch, was gab es sonst noch?
Many Linux GitHub
Also wir könnten jetzt NumPy weglassen, ja
Aber ich will es ja explizit mal mit
Modulenfunktion probieren
Also machen wir mal 2000
Hatten wir jetzt 2014 oder hatten wir jetzt
Chat
Ach das ist das Neueste, was es gibt
Oder was?
CentOS 7
Oh was ist das?
Mani-234?
Ich bin jetzt verwirrt.
Das mit dem Ja verstehe ich ja noch,
aber was bedeutet denn jetzt
228?
Was soll das jetzt bedeuten?
PEP 600 Compliance.
Das ist die
G-Lip C-Version
Ah
Ah, so
Ja, Finn, das Problem ist
Ich benutze
Nampai
Und Nampai
brauche einen neueren
GCC, als ich habe.
Also das ist doof.
Wir machen jetzt testweise es tatsächlich mal ohne
Nampai, weil ich einfach wissen will, ob das
vom Ansatz her funzt.
Das würde dann gar nicht auf Ubuntu 12
laufen.
Na wieso? Warum?
Warum nicht?
Wenn das statisch alles kompiliert ist,
und das soll funktionieren wir probieren jetzt mal was aus hier main punkt bei das kein wimm
drauf was denn das hier los monka es will es machen wir mal kurz hier namen bei weg das da
weg und hallo und das da weg jetzt einfach nur hier install nur rich hoffentlich geht das ok
nice.
Python.
Ne, was? Opt. Wie war das jetzt?
Opt bin
Python main. Okay, das
sollte jetzt an sich laufen.
Macht's auch. Und jetzt
können wir sagen pip
install pyinstaller.
Das funzt auch. Pyinstaller.
Achso,
ist der jetzt auch hier?
Pyinstaller.
One file.
main.py
Okay, bam.
Will nich, warum?
Python was built without a shared library, which is required.
If you build Python from source, rebuild it with...
What the fuck?
Can you deploy it on DevTool?
I don't know what you mean.
Chat, Chat, Chat.
Many Linux error.
There is a key part.
Python. Ja, ist
klar.
Okay, Chatgear, ich
sag mal, der
PyInstaller-Way ist
vielleicht nicht der geilste.
Die kriegen doch im Leben
auch kein
Pythoner für Ubuntu
1204.
Okay, Leute.
Wir werden das mit dem PyInstaller
vielleicht nochmal nachholen, aber
ich glaube, das ist nicht
wirklich gut, da mit SelfContain Anwendungen
zu bauen, die rückwirkend lauffähig sind.
Probleme
zu bilden auf
altem Linux.
Es hört sich sehr
frickelig an.
War Ubuntu 12
auch Python 2? Das kann schon sein,
aber vielleicht gibt es dafür ja eine neuere Interpreter.
Ich habe gedacht, ich benutze diese offiziellen
Python-Images, weil das dann geht.
Aber ja, vielleicht
doch nicht.
Okay, so.
Next.
Pi-App. Leute, ich überspringe das.
Pi-App gucken wir uns auch noch an.
Ich will jetzt einfach mal das da probieren, weil
ich habe so von meinem Bauchgefühl,
ja, von meinem Bauchgefühl
hat sich das hier
eigentlich echt ganz sinnvoll gelesen.
Wenn ich das
richtig verstanden habe, ist es nämlich so,
Python, Nuit,
das Projekt hat vielleicht ein bisschen dummen Namen,
den kann ich mir immer nicht merken.
Nuit, Nuit, Nuitka.
Damit kann man wohl
Python zu C
compilen und dann
statisch linken.
Irgendwie so in der Richtung.
Okay, das gibt's nur dafür.
Dann habe ich eine Idee, was wir jetzt machen.
Dann habe ich eine Idee.
Wie...
Moment.
Install.
Wie installiert man das?
Python?
Mpip?
Okay, okay.
Pass auf.
Idee.
Wir machen uns jetzt ein Docker-File.
Wir machen es erstmal von Hand.
Wir machen es nochmal von Hand.
Also wir starten Manylinux.
Wir gehen nach Opt, Python und dann CP1314.
Was ist eigentlich der Unterschied zwischen CP1314 und CP1314T?
Jemand von euch HighIQ Chatges?
Da so spontan eine Idee.
E ist Turbo.
Ah, verstehe.
Da sollte man immer D nehmen.
Okay.
Das hat schon mal gefunzt.
One file standalone.
Und wie ruft man das jetzt?
Bild it using.
Okay.
Also das heißt, wir machen das nochmal.
Bin.
Python.
Minus.
M.
Ja.
Machen wir mal hier.
Stand alone war das, oder?
Stand alone.
One file.
So, und jetzt sage ich main.py.
Richtig.
Warte mal.
Erstmal im richtigen Verzeichnis.
Wow.
Der will schon mal gar nicht.
Nice.
Automatic Detection of Static LibPython Failed.
Many Linux Has No Shared Libraries.
Use Container With...
Was?
CD, Opt, Internal und und Task Data...
Moment.
Das soll funktionieren?
War T nicht für Threading?
Für den Global Interpreter Log ist das. Aha.
Moment, das hat jetzt funktioniert.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich jetzt gemacht habe.
Es compiled, Leute.
Es macht Dinger.
Es compiled.
Version 3.14.
Commercial Crate not installed.
Wie Commercial Crate.
Wollen die sagen, meine Software ist nicht Business Enterprise ready oder was?
Das deprimiert mich jetzt aber ganz schön, dass das nicht Commercial Create ist, meine Software.
Main.bin
Ah, Module named not found rich.
Okay, der hat schon mal nicht meine Module
included. Das ist natürlich schon mal
doof, ja.
Wie sagt
man dem, dass er Module includen soll?
Ah, mal was anderes.
Ich bin ja auch dumm.
Ich hab
Bridge, glaube ich, gar nicht installiert, oder?
Guck mal.
Main.py
Ich hab Bridge überhaupt nicht installiert.
Okay, Install.
Rich.
Jetzt aber.
Okay, Funst.
Jetzt bilden wir das Ganze nochmal.
Kein Commercial Crate.
Ja, das wird es gewesen sein.
Kein Vampir-Emoji.
Chat, bleib hier noch am Start.
Da bin ich wieder.
Mein Manager, ich nenne es jetzt einfach mal so, klingt jetzt nach mehr als es ist,
hat gerade was geschrieben.
Weil ich muss immer noch die Rechnung schicken.
So.
Okay.
Was ist, was ist bitte
Many Linux? Äh, Moment.
Warum ist das jetzt so krass
langsam? Wahrscheinlich,
weil das Rich noch kompilieren muss.
Alter, was sind das für Bildzeiten?
Das ist ja schlimmer als C++
The fuck?
Das braucht ja 3 Stunden
Aber gut, ey
Wenn es am Ende self-contained ist und funktioniert
Juckt mich nicht
Warum ist das GCCC
Ich denke, da ist nur GCC
Ja, Moment, doch, doch, GCC 10 war drauf
GCC 10 2 war drauf
10 3 hätte das andere gebraucht
Ähm
Okay, die Compile Times sind schon krass
Das ist schon
Heftig
Zum Vergleich
Alter, meine
Mein Ratschneider ist am abkacken
Abkacken.
Zum Vergleich.
Ähm.
Go.
Go Compilation.
Fertig.
Ah, ne.
Ja.
Zum Vergleich.
Go Compilation.
Bam.
Okay, das ist jetzt auch lahm.
Aber fertig.
Fertig, ne.
Self-Contained Binary.
was auf jedem Linux läuft. Jetzt bist du am
futtern Honigmelone.
Okay, die Compile-Speeds sind echt
krass schlecht, Alter.
Könnte das sein, dass
der Compile-Speed so langsam ist,
weil wir,
weil Commercial Create Not
Installed ist, dass das
quasi unoptimiert
bildet, damit man sich die
Commercial-Version kaufen muss.
Das wäre ja, wenn es funktioniert,
relativ Six Head eigentlich von denen.
Weil dann haben trotzdem alle ein gutes Produkt,
was ein bisschen langsamer ist.
Und die Commercial Crate Leute
haben ein gutes Produkt,
plus was schneller ist.
Aber die Bildzeiten sind ja heftig.
Die Bildzeiten,
das ist hier wirklich krass, ey.
Mal gucken, wenn wir NumPy kompilieren.
Das wird ja dann noch viel härter.
Warum sind da überhaupt so viele Files?
Weil das meine Anwendung ist, plus die Dependencies von der Anwendung.
Dependencies ist Rich für Konsolen-Output.
Und Rich hat anscheinend 327 Files.
Und wahrscheinlich selbst wiederum viele Abhängigkeiten.
You are not using CC-Cache.
Ah, install CC-Cache.
Macht es vielleicht schneller.
Warum heißt das hier Klo?
Sklo?
Hättest du den Link am Start für das Projekt?
Du meinst,
die Software, die wir hier gerade bilden
oder
den Compiler, den wir benutzen.
Die Software, die wir hier bilden, ist ein Hello World.
Hier,
nuidk.net
oder such mal
nuidk github.
Kann man echt schlecht schreiben.
Aber ich kann hier nichts rauskopieren,
weil Copy-Paste
zwischen meiner Linux-Kiste und der Windows-Kiste
ein bisschen verbuggt ist.
Nuitka heißt das.
Nuitka.
Also entweder tippst du
der Chat schnell
oder du tippst ab
oder screenshots dir oder so.
So, der hat jetzt compiled.
lgd main.bin
Okay, wir sind abhängig
gegenüber einer libc. Das ist damit
wohl auch so, aber wir können es gegen
eine ganz alte libc kompilieren.
Was schon mal nice ist und es läuft auf neueren Linuxen.
Guck mal hier, da haben wir jetzt.
Main.bin.
Läuft.
Funzt.
Das ist schon mal Daumen hoch.
Ubuntu 12.04.
Schauen wir mal.
Aber das könnte tatsächlich noch ein Ticken zu alt sein.
Main.bin.
Bin.
Äh.
Ich glaube
Ich glaube Rich hat ein paar Probleme
Add Python Encoding
UTF-8
Export
Hit
Leute
Das läuft sogar auf Ubuntu
Und wie groß ist das?
12 MB habt ihr gesagt
Ja ne?
Das ist eigentlich echt ganz ok
Das ist wirklich gar nicht so schlecht.
Gut, auf Alpine mit Muselip C läuft das nicht, weil das immer noch gegen Gelip C linkt.
Aber trotzdem, es hat wenig Abhängigkeit.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht, Leute.
Soll ich euch das mal sagen?
Das ist nicht übel.
Ganz ehrlich, scheiß auf Alpine.
Wer benutzt Alpine für CLI-Tools?
Vielleicht sollte ich besser sagen, es läuft auf allen Linuxen, die ungefähr so alt sind wie Ubuntu, also seit Ubuntu 12.04.
Ganz ehrlich, scheiß auf Alpine.
Alpine ist die einzige größere Distribution, die ich kenne, die Mooselib C verwendet.
Und für Alpine brauchst du keine CLI-Tools.
Ja, es wäre geil, wenn es komplett static wäre, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
Dass es schwierig ist, Python komplett static, so einen Binary mit Python komplett static zu bauen,
weil die vielleicht C-Module nachladen, Fragezeichen,
und du kannst mit einer statisch reingelinkten, kompilierten C-Library kein DL Open machen für dynamische Libraries,
also für SO Libraries unter Linux.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Deswegen kann es durchaus sein, dass es komplett statisch gar nicht so ohne weiteres geht.
Oder es hat Probleme.
Also spätestens bei NumPy kriegt es bestimmt Probleme, wenn man es komplett statisch kompiliert.
Da können wir nochmal suchen.
Vielleicht machen wir morgen nochmal einen Detailstream.
Wo wir dann gucken, ob wir das gegen Muselip C
kompilieren können.
Ja.
Ups.
Muselip C.
Also das ist das, was Alpine
verwendet.
Chatge?
Frage.
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern,
als die ganze
Containerisierungsgeschichte aufgekommen ist.
Am Anfang haben die
Leute, einfach weil die Erfahrung gefehlt hat,
Braindead
Ubuntu Base Image benutzt.
Oder fettes Debian Base Image
oder sowas.
Irgendwann sind sie dann auf die Idee gekommen,
oh, das ist doch nicht so schlau.
Dann kam Alpine um die Ecke
und dann haben alle gesagt, wir verwenden
Alpine, weil wir kleine
Base Images haben wollen.
Ich persönlich bin überhaupt kein Fan
von Alpine. Alpine hat immer wieder
irgendwelche Probleme, beispielsweise
mit DNS-Auflösung.
Ich persönlich mag
drei Sachen
für Container-
Images. Für Go-
Anwendungen mag ich das Scratch-
Image. Das Scratch-Image ist einfach
ein leeres Docker-Image. Kleiner kann
es nicht gehen.
Und nach dem Go-Komplett-Self-Container
läuft eine Go-Anwendung auf dem Scratch-
Image. Also Scratch-Image ist
ein komplett leeres Container-Image
mit der Anwendung dann am Ende drin. Also kleiner
geht es logischerweise nicht mehr.
Das nächste ist Distrolis
Distrolis Debian.
Scheuert, ne?
Dass es Distrolis Debian
gibt.
Ich meine,
die Benahmung ist halt schon
echt ein bisschen
merkwürdig, ne?
Distrolis Static Debian.
Aber das Gute ist,
die Dinger sind auch saumäßig
klein.
So, und das nächste ist Debian Slim.
Debian Slim ist dann für mich das
nächste.
Die drei, die drei mag ich.
Haben wir noch irgendwelche richtig krassen Alpine-Fans,
die sagen, ich bilde alle meine
Container-Images mit Alpine?
Wenn ja, würde mich interessieren,
warum Alpine weiterhin?
Und nicht in Debian Slim oder in
Distrolens oder in Scratch-Image,
wenn es die Anwendung hier gibt.
Mal irgendwelche schnellen
VMs ausprobiert, anstelle von
Containern.
Ich möchte an dieser Stelle
mal auf den VM-Champ verweisen.
Damit konntest du
VMs starten von der Command Line
ähnlich wie Docker-Container.
Aber der war nicht für Highspeed ausgelegt.
Ne, das habe ich in der Tat
noch nicht ausprobiert. Ich weiß,
es gibt von Amazon
ein Projekt,
das nennt sich Firecracker.
Firecracker Micro-VMs.
Meinst du das vielleicht?
Das kenne ich.
Das habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert.
Muss aber, wenn du den passenden
Anwendungsfall hast, sehr nice sein.
Also wenn du
die Isolierung von VMs zwingend
haben möchtest und zusätzlich auch das das so wenig wie möglich auf erhält haben willst was
disk speicher angeht
und halt auch start up time und sowas da ist so was halt cool
Und das uni kraft das weiß ich nicht
Wir schippen anwendung für geräte wir nutzen ausschließlich alpine aus verschiedensten gründen hauptsächlich file size und dependency management im sinne von secure und license tracking
wir müssen aber sowieso notscher ist alpine ich habe da nie probleme also es ist es ist eher so
weil er mal angefangen habe mit alpine zu bilden und das jetzt nicht umstellen wollt und beziehungsweise
was heißt nicht umstellen weil kein wirklichen mehrwert drin seht das umzustellen also jetzt
nichts wo du sagen würdest es muss alpine sein weil anderes geht nicht alpine ist für euch eine
gute kombination und vor allem schafft es schon bestehenden workflow und wollt nicht umstellen
Das kann ich verstehen, ja.
RHEL Base Image.
So, aber lass uns mal weitermachen.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade?
Da habe ich mich ein bisschen sidetracked lassen.
Also das finde ich schon mal, wie gesagt, finde ich schon mal sehr nice.
Dass das hier so einfach funktioniert.
Wir machen uns auch gleich ein Docker-File.
Ihr habt auf den Devices nicht so viel Speicher
Okay
Ist der meiste Speicher nicht
E-Node-JS-Runtime dann?
Weil Distrolis müsste theoretisch noch ein Ticken kleiner sein
Aber ist okay, wenn es für euch passt
Ich will euch ja nicht überzeugen, es hat mich einfach nur interessiert
Ich wollte ja erläutern, was ManyLinux ist.
Also, ManyLinux ist anscheinend zwei Sachen.
Das ist wohl irgendein Standard für Python Binary Sachen.
Oder sowas stand da doch gerade.
PEP 513, PEP 571, PEP 599 und PEP 600.
Und PEP 656, Leute. Merkt euch das.
Ich frage euch morgen
Welche Peps
Sind in Manylinux drin
Morgen im Stream kommt die Frage
Nenne alle Peps von Manylinux
Wer es nicht weiß, bann
Was ist eigentlich ein Pep
So eine blöde Frage zwischendurch
Was Distroless Images sind?
Distroless Images sind die dümmsten benannten Images überhaupt.
Guck hier.
Distroless Debian.
Das sind ganz kleine Container Images.
Oder wir sagen einfach mal das, was das Projekt selber sagt.
Distroless Images contain only your application and its runtime dependencies.
They do not contain packages, bla bla bla.
Die Dependencies ziehen die halt von Debian.
Deswegen nehmen die halt Distrolis.
Deswegen heißt es Distrolis Debian.
Das ist halt einfach ein total dämlicher Name, ja.
That's about 50% of the size of Alpine.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ob jetzt 2 MB oder 5 MB.
Wobei es könnte durchaus sein, dass mit Node.js das gar nicht so easy funktioniert.
Guck mal, es gibt extra...
Vielleicht ist das ja was für euch.
Ohne Mist.
Guck mal, es gibt offizielle
Distroless Node.js
Images.
Vielleicht wäre das was für euch.
Da spart ihr noch ein paar MBs.
Guck mal, sogar Node.js 26.
Ganz neues.
Distroless Node.js 26.
Wenn man versteht, was das macht, geht der Name klar.
Ich finde die Benamung trotzdem übelst
Paintschamp. Distrolis
Devian.
Ich weiß, ja, warum es so heißt.
So, jetzt,
aber, weiter. Moment, Chatkill,
Sidetrack, was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich machen?
Also, was Many, achso,
genau, und dann ist zusätzlich
Many Linux wohl noch
ein,
zu den jeweiligen Standards
Stellen die wohl auch Docker-Files zur Verfügung?
Mit dem Stand von, keine Ahnung, CentOS 7, alter GLIB-C.
Aber alle Tools, die man braucht, um Python-Anwendungen zu bauen.
Für so Keks wie mich, die Binary-Spawn wollen, wahrscheinlich.
Choose my name, da hast du recht.
Wenn du CLI-Tools brauchst, dann kannst du es vergessen.
Unikraft ist eine deutsche GmbH
circa 40 Mitarbeiter
da macht man dann statt Docker Run
einfach Kraft Run
und warum sollte man Kraft verwenden
anstatt was was millionenfach
verbreitet ist auf der Welt
ach das sind dann VMs statt Container
ok
ey das klingt gar nicht so blöd
Naja, klar, klar
Wenn man das braucht
Hör mal auf, Twitter, Alter
Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich hab's am Anfang ja schon gesagt
Ich hab ja gar nichts gegen die meisten Twitter-Posts
Was mich aber halt
echt immer an der
Menschheit zweifeln lässt
sind diese krassen
Selbstdarsteller, die
sich und ihren Leuten öffentlich
immer kundtun müssen auf Twitter
für wie moralisch überlegen und bessere Leute
sie sich halten. Das fuckt mich immer ein bisschen
ab. Der Rest ist mir das Wurscht, was die Leute posten.
Dabi17, danke schön für den
Prime-Sub.
Hast du dir mal
Potman angeschaut? Ja, ich muss
Potman gezwungenermaßen benutzen auf der
Arbeit, weil irgendjemand
auf der Arbeit mal entschieden hat,
was auch tatsächlich
sinnig ist, meiner Meinung nach,
dass der...
Also wenn du
containerisierte Anwendungen auf Servern
laufen lassen willst, bei uns darfst du kein
Docker verwenden. Du musst
rootless-podman verwenden.
Was ist bei dir auf der
Admin-Entwickler?
VM machst es egal.
Wenn du jetzt nicht die Sachen gerade
in einem Kubernetes-Cluster laufen lässt, sondern wenn du
einen Container starten willst auf Servern, der da dauerhaft läuft,
dann musst du podman verwenden. Also ich verwende
ab und zu mal notgedrungen
podman.
Aber jetzt wirklich
Richtig große Checker, was Portman angeht, bin ich nicht.
Was ist der Vorteil, Nachteil?
Also der Vorteil früher war,
klappt bei dir irgendwas nicht mit Portman oder ist es komplizierter?
Ja, wenn du rootless Portman hast, funktioniert halt vieles nicht.
Viele Standard-Images, die root verwenden und root-Rechte haben wollen und sowas, ja.
Dann funzt das nicht
Also das kann schon Probleme machen
Wenn man einfach mal schnell ein Container-Image starten will
Bis den Bastel wieder löscht
Das weiß ich nicht
Da kann man auch Docker nehmen
Keine Ahnung, warum man das machen sollte
So, also wir haben das jetzt kompiliert.
Und lass nochmal kurz, kurz nochmal, Low IQ.
Leute, mein Brain funktioniert gerade nicht mehr.
Wir haben das jetzt kompiliert und wir haben das auch getestet, dass das sogar noch gegen Ubuntu 12.04 läuft.
So.
Hart wurde fett gedono-walled.
Was?
Wo?
Oh, der Scam-Train ist am Start, Leute.
Wartet einfach, bis der abgelaufen ist und dann subscribt.
Easy.
Weil wisst ihr, jeder Sub
Ein IQ Punkt mehr für den gesamten Chat
So, Moment, jetzt muss ich mal kurz
Kurz nochmal in mich gehen, also wir haben den Krempel jetzt
Kompiliert, nur mit Rich
Nur mit Rich, NumPy ist noch nicht dabei
Ne
Das ist 12, so und das ging
Rückwirkend bis Ubuntu 12.04
Dann versuche ich doch mal jetzt
Ein Docker-File zu bauen
Wo man halbwegs
gescheit damit sowas bauen kann.
Wolltest gerade die
Vor- und Nachteile erklären.
Ja gut, die Nachteile, die Vorteile sind,
dass es auf jedem Linux seit Ubuntu
1204 läuft, die auf GLibc basieren.
MuselLibc basierte
Distributionen funktionieren
nicht. Komplett statisch
glaube ich, ist auch nicht so einfach.
Das können wir uns vielleicht morgen oder so mal angucken.
Ansonsten finde ich es ziemlich gut.
ein nachteil den wir gesehen haben sie übertrieben lange compile zeiten du musst
es halt auf einem uralten linux bilden es ist nicht so einfach wie go wo du
go go bild sagt der anwendung fällt raus läuft überall egal wo du es
kompiliert hast und wo das drauf kopiert also ganz einfach ist es nicht
wie groß ist die binary 12 am b das ist vollkommen fein ich meine das muss ja
enthält es ein preis und interpreter das ist wirklich komplett komplett bein und
Da wird ja auch nichts entpackt. Also es gefällt mir schon mal aus dem Grund deutlich besser als PyInstaller. PyInstaller konnten wir nicht so richtig alles testen, weil das Bilden auf der alten Plattform nicht funktioniert hat. Gefällt mir insofern schon mal besser. Keine temporäre Python-Interpreter, der irgendwo temporär ein Verzeichnis ausgepackt werden muss, da dann rumgammelt und es dann wieder startet und so, sondern wirklich echtes Binary mit allem drin, was man braucht.
inklusive dependency support anscheinend.
So, jetzt probieren wir nochmal was anderes.
Jetzt gehen wir mal in unser main.py rein.
Oder auch nicht.
Achso.
Lul.
main.py
Jetzt probieren wir das mal mit numpy aus.
numpy
So, python
minus
main.py
12 MB ist aber schon wild.
Du meinst jetzt...
Ja.
Ey, da ist komplett rich und alles drin.
Ganz ehrlich, du wirst wahrscheinlich für die nächsten Sachen, die du hast, gar keinen so großen Anstieg sehen.
Es ist halt ein Hello World mit kompletter Konsolen-Tui-Library dabei.
Und ich glaube halt, Python ist nicht so clever wie der ein oder andere C-Compiler und sagt,
Ach, der Teil wird nicht benutzt.
Ich include den nicht.
Ich glaube, wenn du das als Dependency hast,
wird das...
Wir können ja mal googeln.
Hier, warte mal.
Smaller Binaries.
Vielleicht geht das ja.
Ach, guck mal hier.
Use flag-s
to skip the side modules,
strip, debug, exclude unused large packages
and build in standalone
only for what you code explicitly
import.
Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
dass das nix...
Ach, gucke mal.
Ha!
Dann machen wir das doch mal.
Unsupported Python Flagasp.
Geil!
Achso, Moment, es ist nicht gleich S, es ist minus S.
Die KI lügt, Leute.
Das ist ja auch eine sehr obvious, einprägsame, jeder-kommt-von-sich-auf-draus-Kommandozeilen-Option, oder?
Minus, minus Python, minus Flex, minus Groß S.
Oh, oder auch nicht.
Äh.
No such option?
Okay, äh...
Äh...
What the fuck?
Wo ist es doch gleich?
Äh...
Das ist mir zu high IQ.
Ach so, meinst du?
Nee.
No such option.
Oder so?
So. Ah ja. Okay, jetzt haben wir alles durch.
Wow. Das flutscht ja mal richtig.
Tschätke, es geht steil.
Es geht voll ab jetzt
Okay, ich hab nix gesagt
Fuck, es ist immer noch lahm wie Sau
Scheiße, jetzt kommt das eigentliche Compilen erst ran
Gut, Moment, hab ich
Chat, wer hat aufgepasst?
Wer hat aufgepasst?
Hab ich jetzt Numpile schon drin oder nicht?
Weil, dann ist das jetzt mit Numpile
Hab ich Nampai schon drin jetzt gehabt?
Ja man, aufgepasst, Chatgis
Also hier würde ich definitiv
Von mehr CPU-Kernen profitieren
Ich hab Nampai nicht drin
Okay, dann lassen wir das jetzt nochmal kompilieren
Wir müssen da jetzt leider
machen wir mal hier eine Runde
Entspannungsprogramm.
Irgendwas kompiliert.
Oder für die
Hackermans.
Chat, was ist euch lieber?
Hackermans oder Entspannungsprogramm?
Ist CC Cash aktiv?
Ja.
Glaub schon.
Fischis, okay.
Also die C-Version von Hello World hat 12...
Ja gut, das ist ja keine Frage, dass das kleiner ist.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, wenn du einen Rust-Binary baust...
Achso, ist es die C-Version mit...
Kannst du eine C-Version mal kompilieren?
Mit statisch gelingter C-Library?
Achso
Also du hast jetzt
GLIPC gelinkt
Auch wenn man das eigentlich nicht soll
Aber zum Testen ist ja okay
Okay, das ist das natürlich klein
Ja, ich gehe mal davon aus, selbst eine Rust-Anwendung
Mit statischem
Lipmusel-Target
Ist auch nicht viel größer
Go-Anwendungen sind schon ein Ticken größer
Die bringen ja auch einiges mit
Ah, 12K ist Dynamic
Okay, würde mich mal interessieren, wie groß das ist mit statischer C-Library
Aber das ist immer noch unter einem Megabyte wahrscheinlich
12 MB ist schon ordentlich im Vergleich zu anderen Programmiersprachen
Aber ganz ehrlich, für eine Python-Anwendung finde ich das vollkommen okay
Weil ansonsten, im anderen Falle, müsstest du einen kompletten Interpreter mitbringen
Und alles mögliche, das ist dann noch fetter
887 Static, ja.
Da dachte ich mir das irgendwie in dem Dreh.
Aber es ist natürlich schon ein Riesenunterschied, das stimmt.
So, wir haben
fertig, komm.
L.
I
Ritt. Wir haben fertig
kompiliert, Leute. Nein!
Es fängt wieder an.
Aufhören.
Stopp.
Z-Lip-Braucher.
One-Five-Z.
Okay, er ist fertig. Also, wie groß ist
der Campbell jetzt?
12 MB. Okay, es macht überhaupt keinen
Unterschied, ob ich
Flag S oder nicht S mache.
Geht dem komplett sonst wo
vorbei.
Gut, Main.py
Moment, ich hab
doch... Ah, ich hab ein Ampi nicht.
Moment, geht das jetzt überhaupt?
Main.bin
Ja, not found.
Wollte ich grad sagen. Na gut.
Also, der checkt nicht, ob ich dumm bin.
Wär auch blöd, wenn er
das checken würde, weil er müsste ja permanent drauf kommen,
dass das so ist.
Aber der glaubt mir einfach, dass das, was in meinem Python-Skript drin steht, auch das ist, was ich haben will.
Also auch, wenn es gar nicht funktioniert.
Okay, dann installieren wir jetzt mal NumPy.
Lass den Stream schauen.
Was? Welchen Stream?
pip install
numpy
hoffentlich
ah das funzt jetzt ja hier auch nicht
weil numpy braucht ja
moment moment moment Leute numpy braucht ja
den
den neueren gcc
und wir haben nur einen alten gcc
können wir nicht einfach ein altes
numpy
version gcc
Okay.
Nampal 2.
2.32.
Okay.
Geht das so?
Gleich, gleich, 2, 3, 2.
Ah.
Guck mal.
Und schon funzt es.
Excellent.
Okay, jetzt ist er wieder hart am reinkompilen.
Ist die 12 MB Binary aber Static?
Nein.
Die ist static, alles was Python anbelangt.
libc ist dynamisch gelinkt.
Allerdings dadurch, dass ich auf einer ganz alten Distro baue, die extra dafür von Red Hat gebaut wird, geht das auch auf neueren.
Aber nur auf neueren glibc basierten Linux System natürlich.
Also Alpine kannst du klicken.
Jemand von euch in letzter Zeit NumPy kompiliert, wie lange dauert sowas denn?
Ich hab das noch nie gemacht.
NumPy ist doch so ein High-IQ-Python-Projekt.
Nicht, dass es jetzt eine halbe Stunde kompiliert oder so.
Ich mein, das ist schon...
Das haut schon rein.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Ja, SSH mit SS Schmidt.
Go ist da einfach der King, was das angeht.
Der Goat, was Portable und Self-Content-Binaries angeht.
das Ding kannst du irgendwo
kompilieren, solange du nicht
irgendwelche
C-Interop-Geschichten machst, dann hast du
letztendlich ja wieder die gleichen Probleme.
Das kannst du
irgendwo kompilieren, auf
irgendeinem Linux, scheißegal auf welchem,
und dann auf irgendein anderes
Linux draufschmeißen, seit
Kernel 2632 und es läuft.
Der RAM ist auch ganz
schön ausgelastet, ja.
Naja.
Vielleicht war
NumPy doch nicht die beste Idee.
Oh, doch, wir haben es gleich.
Chat, gleich ist es soweit.
Bam.
Okay, jetzt
gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze läuft.
Kunst.
Und jetzt, jetzt kompilieren wir es.
Jetzt kompilieren wir es nochmal.
Und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich mach das komische Flag wieder weg.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Also erstens, wie lange es jetzt dauert.
Wenn es jetzt irgendwie Viertelstunde dauert oder so,
quäle ich euch nicht damit.
Dann gucken wir uns was anderes
in der Zeit an. Wir haben ja hier noch
mehr draufstehen.
Mal gucken. Aber mich interessiert,
könnte der überhaupt mit
NumPy kompilieren?
Oh, fuck.
Jetzt haben wir noch mehr Module. Oh, das wird...
Oh, das wird...
Das wird drei Stunden
Compile-Time wird es geben oder sowas.
Letztendlich muss ich aber ehrlich sagen,
mich juckt
die Compile-Time. Also ich finde es kacke.
Ja. Aber solange
das im Rahmen bleibt, ja, also
so irgendwie unter
einer Viertelstunde oder so, ist das
fein. Wann machst du mal eine neue
CLI-Tool-Version?
Ja, jetzt sind hier neue Sachen
sind dabei gekommen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, ich habe auch keine Ahnung, was die alle treiben
Es ist eh enorm schwierig, in den meisten Sprachen wirklich echte Self-Contained Binaries zu bauen
Unter Windows ist es tatsächlich einen Ticken einfacher
Weil Windows halt rückwärtskompatibel, vor- und rückwärtskompatibel ist
Die letzten 100 Jahre
Aber unter Linux ist das echt ein bisschen eklig
Ich kenne auch keine andere Sprache, die mit Go mithalten kann.
Bei Rust geht das noch ganz gut.
Oh, guck mal, die gecachten Files.
Bei Rust geht das noch ganz gut, wenn du static lip c musel target nimmst.
Dann ist das okay.
Aber mit statischem Linken ist halt immer das Ding,
du kannst halt nicht ohne weiteres statisch linken.
deine C-Library mit dabei
und noch dynamisch
Sachen zur Runtime laden wollen.
Das unterstützen die halt nicht.
Genau, genau.
Das geht mit Trick 17.
Es gibt Hacks,
dass man quasi
dynamische
oder Shared Libraries laden kann,
auch wenn man Static kompiliert hat,
aber das ist alles sehr hacky.
So richtig supported ist es nicht.
Ich glaube, DL Open
Failed halt einfach direkt
Wenn du
Statisch gelinkt hast
Deswegen ist Go halt echter King
Was das angeht, die haben halt alles selbst implementiert
Alles mit drin, keine Abhängigkeiten
Ja, Musel kannst du auch nicht
Lip C Musel kannst du auch nicht
Gescheit statisch linken
Also das ist noch deutlich besser als
G Lip C statisch zu linken, das stimmt schon
Das Problem ist, dass
du kannst auch mit
libcmusel keine
dynamischen Libraries nachladen.
Genau. Es ist bei musel
genau das gleiche.
Sobald du dlopen machst,
geht es nicht, wenn es
statisch gelinkt ist.
Das heißt, eigentlich das Einzige, was dir übrig
bleibt, wenn du so ein richtig schönes
Linux-Binary haben willst,
was läuft auf allen Distributionen der letzten
14 Jahre oder so,
dann musst du das auf irgendeiner uralt-Distribution kompilieren.
Weil GLibc ist halt vorwärtskompatibel, aber nicht rückwärtskompatibel.
Ne, Moment. Wie ist das?
Rückwärtskompatibel, aber nicht vorwärtskompatibel.
Die neuen Libcs haben noch die ganzen Symbols und Gedöns von den alten Versionen,
aber die alten Versionen nicht von den neuen.
Aber ich sehe, du kannst den Pain nachvollziehen,
was Binary Spawn angeht.
Ich sehe, du hast damit auch schon Erfahrung gemacht.
So, guck mal, jetzt haben wir hier
Main.bin.
Leute, es funzt.
Das ist ja richtig geil.
Wisst ihr das?
Das ist ja mega, dieses Tool, Alter.
Guck mal, wir können das aktuelle Python verwenden.
Wir können das Ding in Standalone Binary packen.
Standalone in Anführungsstrichen.
Es ist nicht so Standalone wie Go.
Aber es ist lauffähig auf 99% aller Linuxe der letzten 14 Jahre.
Also viel besser geht es nur noch in Go.
Ich glaube, das werden wir für Python nicht toppen können.
Da kann man nichts
Ich glaube, das kann man echt nicht mehr toppen
Einziger Nachteil, den ich jetzt sehe
Compile-Zeiten
Weil, guckt es euch an
Wobei, cc-cache regelt jetzt wahrscheinlich das neue Bild auch halbwegs
SIG
SIG habe ich mal ganz kurz ausprobiert
In einem Stream
Oder haben wir doch, Chat
Chat, erinnert sich noch jemand an den SIG-Stream?
Oder halluziniere ich jetzt, dass wir mal einen SIG-Stream gemacht haben?
Wir können... Ah, ich gucke jetzt nicht immer schief.
Von 12 auf 19 MB.
Ja, jetzt ist ja auch NumPy noch mit drin.
Ah doch, jetzt die Compile-Zeiten mit CC-Cache geht.
Ja, das geht doch.
Klar.
Guck mal hier, 2 Minuten Build-Time oder so.
Vollkommen okay.
Was ich bei SIG eklig fand,
die hatten irgendwie so eine ganz merkwürdige...
Ich kann mich da gar nicht dran erinnern.
So eine ganz merkwürdige Pointer-Syntax.
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung sah das aus.
Das war super weird.
Das sah aus wie so ein Smiley.
Ja, aber das ist ja richtig geil.
Damit hätte ich ja nicht gerechnet.
Bam. Es läuft einfach.
Also zu welchen...
Wir fragen mal ChatGPT.
Welche Linux
Distros
setzen nicht
auf G
Lip C. Also mir fällt aus dem
Bauch, Chat, Frage an
euch, außer Alpine,
fällt euch noch was ein?
Linus Distro, jetzt nicht
googeln, nicht googeln und KI fragen,
wenn ihr es aus dem Kopf wisst.
Busybox ist doch keine Distro,
das ist so ein
so ein Shell-Gedöns
mit allen Tools drin.
Android.
Android, da hätte ich überhaupt nicht
dran gedacht. Ja, das kann sein. Auf was
setzt denn Android?
Irgendwas Google-Eigenes, oder?
Was haben
die da?
Devuan?
Ist das nicht
die Geschichte mit
kein System D?
Okay, bam.
Wir fragen mal.
Alpine.
Void Linux. Aha.
Okay, es gibt beides von Void Linux.
Chimera Linux.
Adeli habe ich noch nie gehört.
Open, okay. OpenWrt.
Alles klar.
Okay.
Das könnte tatsächlich sogar ein Problem
werden, ne?
wenn man eigene Tools
bauen will
erinnert sich noch einer dran, wir haben mal
ein Tool in Go programmiert
oder war es in .NET, ich weiß es
gar nicht mehr, wir haben mal ein Tool
programmiert, was auf meinem
Videorekorder
lauffähig war
also Videorekorder ist der Boomer
Ausdruck für, das ist
so eine Kiste mit DVB-C Tuner
und eine SSD drin und kann Sachen aufnehmen.
Das ist kein Videorekorder mit Magnetkassetten oder sowas.
Ich kann mich ja auch per SSH auf meinen Videorekorder verbinden.
Und da hatten wir tatsächlich, ich glaube es war ein .NET Programm,
ein .NET Programm kompiliert gegen irgendwie ARM V7 oder so,
irgendwas ganz uraltes, was auf meinem Videorekorder lief.
und das haben wir dann per ssh drauf kopiert
und es ging auch
wenn das
eine andere c-library als glibc verwendet
dann würde das hier nicht funktionieren
aber ich glaube mal ganz ehrlich
chat, wenn jemand
eine software für seinen videorekorder
entwickeln will, dann wird das wahrscheinlich
nicht unbedingt in python machen
und als standalone binary bundeln wollen, oder?
ich glaube, da nimmt er was anderes
das ist jetzt nicht so
der primäre Anwendungsfall dafür.
Bionic, die Lip C von Android.
Also ist jetzt nicht wirklich nennenswert.
Für CLI Tools.
Ich bin echt begeistert.
Das ist viel besser, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Also meine persönliche
Sache, wo ich am Anfang gedacht habe,
das könnte gut funktionieren, ist das
und das. Aber das ist richtig gut.
Wir gucken uns morgen dann an, wie das hier mit Alpine funktioniert, ob man nicht vielleicht sogar alles statisch reinlenken kann.
Dann ist das Binary auf jeden Fall ein bisschen größer.
Aber das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Ich finde das mega nice. Ich finde das wirklich top.
Sonst gucken wir nochmal, ob das immer noch unter Ubuntu 12.04 läuft.
Warte mal, Ubuntu 10.04, bam.
Oh, gibt es nicht mehr.
Oh
1104?
Oh Mist
Ok Ubuntu
Ok machen wir mal was anderes
Ähm
Was ist Chat
Was ist die älteste Linux Distribution
Die es als Docker Image gibt
Offiziell
Debian
Debian 5
Ne
Äh
Cent OS 5.
Fuck.
Leute.
Es ist Cent OS 5.
MonkaS.
Cent OS 5.
Fuck.
Es ist Cent OS 5.
CentOS 5 Release Date
Ne, ne, das kann nicht sein
Das kann nicht sein
Okay, das ist noch älter
Debian Archive
Okay, geile Sache
Edge
Damit habe ich angefangen Linux zu lernen damals
Ich hatte noch den Vorgänger kurz und danach hatte ich Edge.
Das war mein erstes Linux, mit dem ich mich richtig ernsthaft auseinandergesetzt habe.
Ich habe ja dann auch die Ausbildung hier gemacht.
Davor war Woody, glaube ich.
Also für Leute, die es nicht wissen, das sind alles Toy-Story-Namen.
Die Dinger haben immer Toy-Story-Charakter.
Die Deviant-Distribution.
Edge. Alter. Das ist ja antik.
Okay, warte mal
CentOS
Data
Das ist so alt, das geht bestimmt nicht mehr, oder?
Main.bin
Ne, okay
CentOS
CentOS 5 ist zu alt
CentOS, das von uns nicht
Aber, wir können mal gucken
Funktioniert CentOS 6 schon?
Also es sollte
Alles seit 2012 funktionieren
Das ist, übrigens, um euch jetzt
Ah, das geht auch nicht, um euch jetzt nochmal
Die Vorteile zu zeigen, ne, von
Von Go
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal kurz, hier
Run
CentOS, pass mal auf CentOS 4
Okay, ne, das ist ganz abgesehen
Und das ist halt das geile an Go
Leute, ja, mit Go
Gar kein Problem, Funst
App
Bam
Go ist das Beste, was sowas angeht
Das einzige Dependency, was Go hat, ist
Du musst mindestens
Kernel 2, 6, 32 haben
Mal Go
Minimum Kernel
Oh
Es wurde
Es wurde angepasst, Leute
Es wurde angepasst
Es war mal
2, 6
Und jetzt sind es
Jetzt ist es Kernel 3, 2 oder later
We don't support CentOS 5
Ja gut, aber ich habe ja den Container
Genau, Go benutzt bei Default aber auch kein libc.
Nee, gar nichts. Die haben das alles selbst implementiert.
Okay, dann ist der Test aber nicht fair, den ich gemacht habe.
Wenn Go nur eine Abhängigkeit gegen meinen Kernel hat,
dann läuft das schlicht und ergreifend auf jeder Distribution, die ich im Container starten kann.
Weil Kernel ist ja der gleiche wie auf dem Host.
Also wenn wir jetzt eine VM starten würden mit CentOS 5 und Kernel 2618, dann würde es wahrscheinlich nicht funktionieren.
Aber im Ernst, Chat, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber ich glaube, wir können es verkraften, wenn CentOS 5 nicht mehr supported ist.
Es gibt Schlimmeres.
Oder jemand von euch
noch in der
misslichen Lage.
Ja, sobald du
C-Gob brauchst, ist es eh vorbei.
Dann hast du die gleichen Probleme.
Dann ist
vorbei.
Aber ich bin trotzdem begeistert.
Das gefällt mir richtig gut.
Damit würde sich Go, äh nicht Go, damit würde sich Python echt ganz gut eignen für CLI-Apps.
CentOS 5 läuft sicher noch produktiv.
Ey, wir haben noch Solaris produktiv laufen auf der Arbeit.
Ja, irgendwas uraltes gibt es immer noch.
Freust du dich auf die nächste BlizzCon?
Es gab mal eine Zeit, da habe ich mich mega gefreut auf die BlizzCon.
Aber das ist schon jahrelang
nicht mehr so.
Und die letzten Jahre war auch nichts Spannendes.
Für World of Warcraft
Enjoyer ist das immer nice.
Die quasi live
World of Warcraft spielen und da
immer auf die nächste Expansion geiern.
Verstehe ich.
Ja.
Aber ansonsten
Overwatch juckt mich auch nicht mehr.
Wobei Overwatch
ein echt geiles Game war.
Also es ist das letzte Game, wo ich so richtig
Hardcore gecrindet hab, hunderte Stunden und alles
Overwatch
Aber es gibt halt nix
Was mich, Diablo 4
War ich ganz kleines bisschen
Hab ich mich drauf gefreut
Aber ich hab den Release diesmal abgewartet
Und hab
Die ersten paar Wochen gewartet
Und hab ich schon gesehen, okay, doch nicht so geil
Und ansonsten
Tja.
Gibt's da nicht so viel, ne?
Die hatten ja auch die letzten Jahre nicht viel zum ankündigen.
Ist jetzt wieder geil.
PoE 2?
Ich hab angefangen PoE 2 zu spielen.
Hat mich aber nicht gleich
so krass gecatcht wie PoE 1.
PoE 1 kann ich immer mal wieder
bisschen Kreiselcrime machen.
Apoe2? Vielleicht soll ich
Apoe2 nochmal eine Chance geben.
Aber bevor wir jetzt
zu sehr sidetracked werden, Chat,
mal Frage an euch, die
geguckt haben,
wie findet ihr dieses Python
zu C-Compiler
Ding hier, mit
einem 19 MB Binary,
was lauffähig ist
seit Ubuntu 12.04
und alle Dependencies enthält, außer
GLIB-C?
Das ist richtig nice, oder?
Also das werde ich in Zukunft wahrscheinlich öfters benutzen.
Das bedeutet auch...
Okay, Chat.
Dann habe ich schon was, was wir in den nächsten Streamsort machen können.
Streamsort.
Bisschen unnötig.
Echt, warum?
Wie willst du sonst...
Wie willst du sonst eine Python-CLI-App gescheit verteilen?
Wir reden jetzt ja nicht von irgendwelchen Web-Backends.
gar nicht, das ist natürlich auch
gut, man kann es auch einfach sein lassen
dann hast du die Probleme nicht, ja, verstehe ich
aber
ansonsten kannst du halt keine CLI Apps
Lieblings Python Buch
ich habe nur ein Python Buch in meiner ganzen
Zeit gelesen, das war 2000
keine Ahnung
5 oder 4 oder so
das ist ewig her
das war noch Python 2
und
irgendwie bin ich
hab ich versucht damals
mir Programmieren ordentlich beizubringen
damit, aber
war nicht so geil.
So richtig angefangen
mit Programmieren hab ich dann erst mit C Sharp
und später dann mit
allen möglichen JavaScript, Go
leider, leider
auch, es ist zwar immer
anstrengend, aber leider auch
C++ ab und zu
die schlimmste Programmiersprache überhaupt.
Also nächste Stream-Source.
Ich will dann noch mal
rumprobieren mit
anderen
Compile-Tools
für Python oder
libcmusel
für...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Nuitcast. Scheißname, ey. Das kann man nicht aussprechen.
Ist NetCup eigentlich legit?
Ja.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, ob das NetCup war oder OVH.
Ich hab mal... Also, nehmen wir das jetzt mal mit einer Prise Skepsis.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ob es NetCup oder OVH war.
Ich wollte mir da mal einen Server mieten.
Ansonsten gehe ich ja immer zu Hetzner.
Und auch immer noch, ja.
Ich hab mir gedacht, probierst du mal was anderes Haus.
Da habe ich mir dann einen Server gemietet.
Und auf einmal kriege ich eine E-Mail.
Irgendwie diese Ressourcen können nicht bereitgestellt werden.
Weil sie brauchen einen Identitätsnachweis, ob ich meinen Ausweis fotografieren könnte und ihn per Mail schicken.
Da habe ich gesagt, ne, kann ich nicht.
Dann kein Server bei euch.
Und seitdem habe ich die nie wieder ausprobiert.
Also Hetzner wollte das von mir nicht.
Hetzner war da komplett
problemlos.
Hetzner ist teurer geworden.
Die sind alle teurer geworden.
Du brauchst das nur für drei Monate.
Wenn du...
Also bei Hetzner kann ich dir sagen,
Hetzner rechnet stündlich ab.
Du kannst dir einen Server
auch nur für 2 Stunden
mieten. Wir hatten uns mal
Cloud Pricing
Wir hatten uns mal
hier
NetCap auch. Ja, glaube ich.
Wir hatten uns mal
hier was gekauft und zwar
Hatten die nicht so
eine Übersicht mal?
Du nimmst den kostenlosen Sommer bei Oracle, ja, bis sie dich abstellen.
Da kannst du dich nicht drauf verlassen.
Also wir hatten uns mal so eine ganz fette Kiste hier gemietet.
Das war wahrscheinlich dann sogar schon eher sowas hier.
Das war eine richtig fette Kiste.
Ja, sowas hier in der Richtung haben wir uns mal gemietet.
853 Euro im Monat, aber nur für, was Cloud oder Dedicated Cloud, aber nur für drei Stunden.
Das heißt, ich habe dann am Ende damals irgendwie 2,50 Euro oder so bezahlt.
Ich habe mir das Ding damals gemietet, um Open Street, wie heißt die Open Street-Mail?
Open Street Maps, genau.
Um Open Street Maps zu preprocessen für Routenplanung.
Ich hatte so ein kleines Bastelprojekt damals mit einem Kollegen zusammen.
Und dazu mussten wir, um die Routenplanung damit machen zu können, mussten wir irgendwelche Open Street Maps processen.
Und das braucht RAM as fuck.
Und Rechenleistung as fuck.
Da habe ich mir damals, das haben wir sogar im Stream gemacht, da habe ich mir damals so ein Ding gemietet für drei Stunden und habe am Ende 2,50 Euro bezahlt.
Also wie gesagt, wenn du es nur für kurze Zeit brauchst, auch unterhalb von einem Monat, kannst du dir das hier kaufen.
Was bei Hetzner auch immer geht, wo du mal preislich gucken musst, ist Server-Auktion.
Server-Auktion geht aber, glaube ich, nur monatsweise, oder, Chat?
Wisst ihr, wie das ist?
Ich glaube, Mindestlaufzeit ist ein Monat bei der Serverauktion, gell?
Und du musst auch eine Setup-Gebühr bezahlen, wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz falsch liege.
Was heißt denn, stundenweise wird die Kiste wieder platt gemacht oder kann man die hochfahren und dann wird abgerechnet?
Die Kiste wird platt gemacht.
Also solange die Kiste angelegt ist, kostet sie.
Also wenn du sagst, ich möchte diese fette Kiste haben, dann legt Hetzner die an und fährt die hoch und du kannst dich darauf einloggen.
Wenn du die dann runterfährst oder ausschaltest, aber die noch professioniert ist für dich, dann bezahlst du weiter.
Erst wenn du sie löscht, kostet es nichts mehr.
Gibt keine Setup-Gebühr.
Okay.
Aber Mindestlaufzeit, Mindestlaufzeit ist,
ist, glaube ich, ein Monat hier.
Also Server-Auktionen kannst du auch mal gucken,
ob da was dabei ist.
Ja, da kriegst du hier echt ganz gute Kisten.
Ne?
64 Gigramm.
8 Core oder so, was das ist.
Wir machen hier einfach mal, guck mal hier,
Price.
50, gibt's nicht.
60.
Ja, naja.
Kannst du mal gucken.
Vielleicht ist auch Server-Auktion was für dich.
Aber ich finde diese Cloud-Dinger immer praktisch.
Brauchst du dann eher eine fette Kiste
oder tut es dir auch eine
Low-Budget?
Ja, das geht.
Ich meine, du kannst das beliebig optimieren.
Du kannst bei Headset
mit Terraform Server aufbauen
und destroyen. Das geht.
Also du kannst da wirklich solche
Dinger machen wie
auf Knopf drücken, Server
wird erstellt, mountet sich
alles rein, was es braucht.
Knopf drücken,
Server ist wieder weg. Also du kannst das
schon maximieren.
Eher was fetteres, also mit viel RAM.
Okay.
Ja, wenn du
dann würde ich mal bei der
Server-Auktion gucken. Da findest du ältere
Hardware, meistens ein bisschen ältere Hardware,
aber CPUs sind eigentlich schnell genug,
egal was du da hast der letzten paar Jahre.
Und RAM gibt's
da auch noch ganz gut.
Weil die Preise
an sich sind halt
schon echt
nicht ganz ohne.
Mal gucken, was die
Regular Performance, die fetteste Kiste ist.
Ja.
Das ist halt nicht ohne.
Ja, da musst du schon mal hier...
Selbst die fetteste Kiste
bei der...
Die mittleren Server fetteste Kiste
32 Gig,
16 Cores, 238 Euro im Monat.
Das haut schon rein.
Ja, dann würde ich lieber
jetzt eine Server-Auktion gucken.
Da hast du ganz gut...
Da hast du...
wenn du Glück hast, findest du da ganz gut was.
Guck mal, hier kriegst du zum Beispiel
ein, ist das ein 8-Kerner?
Ah, 4-Kerner, 4 Quad-Core.
Ja, aber hier kriegst du ein Quad-Core
mit 64 GB RAM
und 2x 256 GB SSD.
Also wenn es hier hauptsächlich um viel RAM geht,
wirst du es kaum viel billiger kriegen
als sowas hier.
Es ist nicht einfach gerade
günstige Hardware zu kaufen
oder mieten
Aber NetCap ist auch legit
NetCap, OVH
DigitalOcean
Das taugt alles
Du musst dir keine Gedanken machen
Ist halt die Frage immer
wenn man sich einen Server kaufen will
will man vielleicht noch mehr Services haben
Also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel sagst, ja, ich brauche einen Server für mein Web-Anwendungs-Backend und da muss richtig ordentlich Power drin sein, aber ich brauche auch noch eine Datenbank und will mich da nicht selbst drum kümmern, dann würde ich nach einem Anbieter gucken, der Managed-Datenbanken anbietet.
Also DigitalOcean zum Beispiel
bietet Managed Datenbanken an.
Hetzner glaube ich
nicht.
Aber es gibt noch ein paar andere Anbieter, die
Managed Postgres und sowas anbieten.
Ohne, dass du jetzt gleich zu Google oder Azure
oder AWS rennen musst, weil da bezahlst du dich
dumm und dämlich.
So, und also, das
könnten wir mal ausprobieren. Und
Chat, was wir
jetzt uns damit mal beschäftigen müssen was haltet ihr davon wenn wir uns in dem stream mal angucken
wie man gescheite peyton cli apps überhaupt erstellt weil ich habe keine ahnung was command
line parsing angeht in peyton da muss man gucken was für gescheit libraries gibt oder auch wie man
rich gescheit verwendet ich würde sagen wir bauen mal eine command line app so irgend so ein beispiel
ding mit mit 34 optionen und dann ein bisschen blödsinn drin wir bauen wieder
eine komandozeilen app leute die wichtigste komandozeilen app überhaupt
was sie können muss ist moment ich zeige euch da muss ich jetzt hier über
switchen weil ich meine vm starten muss sekunde hierüber
was man auf das wichtigste feature ich denke mal ihr wisst schon aber das
wichtigste feature was eine cli app heutzutage können muss muss ich euch
hier zeigen, weil die App habe ich nur auf meiner alten
VM drauf.
So wichtig ist das.
Ja.
Das wichtigste Feature.
VM Champ.
VM Champ Kekwe.
Oh.
Okay, mit 8 Bit Zeichen ist vielleicht doch nicht so geil.
Sekunde. Erkennt ihr, habt ihr es erkannt?
Chat, habt ihr es erkannt, was das war?
Auch in diesem Frame Buffer Terminal.
vmchamp
kekw
Das ist das wichtigste Feature.
Das mit Abstand wichtigste Feature,
was eine CLI App können muss.
Ich glaube, wir müssen
in Python CLI
kekw as a service
programmieren.
Und bei der Gelegenheit
auch ein bisschen lernen,
wie das funktioniert.
So, jetzt muss ich erstmal das Ding hier wieder ausschalten, weil ich habe jetzt so viele Sachen.
Also, Chat, jetzt bin ich auch verwirrt.
Jetzt bin ich echt verwirrt.
Also, weil jetzt habe ich hier meine Linux, vor allem im Fullscreen.
Hier mein Windows.
Und hier meine...
Mein Linux-Mini-PC.
Das ist mir jetzt zu viel.
Da muss ich den erstmal wieder ausschalten.
Leaked. Fuck, Alter.
Hätte ich es euch nicht gezeigt, kein Keck.
W.
Aber das machen wir.
Dann würde ich sagen, Chat,
wir haben doch morgen sonst nichts Großartiges vor.
Außer ich könnte ein bisschen MMO-Kreisel-Crime machen.
Was haltet ihr davon,
wenn wir uns morgen mal
angucken,
CLI-Apps mit Python?
So, Kommandozeilen-Argumente machen,
Kommandozeilen-Argumente parsen,
Environment-Variablen einlesen.
So die Basic-Sachen, die man braucht.
Oder sagt ihr, weiß ich schon,
juckt mich nicht.
Wenn ihr sagt, weiß ich schon, juckt mich nicht,
dann muss ich es auch nicht machen, weil
das ist jetzt nix,
wo ich mir gar nichts
Besseres vorstellen könnte.
Und wenn ihr gar nichts schreibt, ist auch okay.
Dann weiß ich, dass es keinen wirklich juckt.
Oh, das ist nämlich nett.
Dann machen wir irgendwas anderes.
Weil es ist ja...
Ich interessiere mich jetzt.
Weil es ist ja nicht so, als hätten wir nicht genug Sachen,
die wir noch machen müssen.
Oh ne, Chat.
Das müssen wir auch noch irgendwann.
Wann ist der Stream? Irgendwann morgen.
Ich kann es ja noch nicht genau sagen.
Morgen muss ich erstmal meinen Long Run erledigen.
Irgendwas zwischen 11 und 15 Kilometer.
Mal gucken, was mein Garmin-Trainingsplan
da morgen ausspuckt.
Und danach habe ich den ganzen Tag eigentlich Zeit.
Diesen Mist müssen wir auch noch machen.
Wir müssen uns den Netzwerkkartentreiber kompilieren für das NAS.
Chat, wo habt ihr mehr Bock drauf?
Für die nächsten Tage, sage ich mal.
Also falls das morgens
Oder morgen, je nachdem, ob das morgen was wird
Für den nächsten Stream
Was ist euch lieber?
Python CLI App stellst, bisschen lernen
Oder mich abquälen
Mit diesem fucking Realtek Netzwerkkartentreiber
Ich seh da OpenCloud, wann gibt's das?
Danach
Ey, buy das nicht
Realtek
Vielleicht machen wir es auch so
Vielleicht machen wir morgen Python CLI Apps
Und am Sonntag
Quäle ich mich ein bisschen mit dem Realtek Treiber
Wieso muss man den Realtek Treiber
Selbst kompilieren
Das ist eine sehr
Gute
Und berechtigte Frage
Warum man das machen muss
Die Antwort ist
Weil der Realtek Treiber
Scheiße ist
Realtek ist lustig
Ja geil
Da gehe ich auch von aus, dass Realtek lustiger wird
Also
Das Problem ist QPA
Oder spricht man nicht
Opa aus
So wie Opa
Nur mit Q
Also das Problem ist
Ich hab, nur kurz
Dann muss ich was essen, um 20 Uhr muss ich rüber
Also, ich hab hier
ein Nass.
So, dieses Teil.
Das Nass hat ein
Realtag.
Geil, sieht man wieder nicht.
Oder haben sie wieder nicht.
Die basteln auch jeden Tag
an ihrer Seite rum, Mann.
Habt ihr irgendwo
den Knopf, die Details gesehen?
Sicht.
Hier, ich will es sichten.
Kupa
Achso
Oh, das ist Pfeiffer der Name, das gefällt mir
Okay, die
Die Seite, ach hier ist es doch, hier
Ja, das hat hier
einen Realtag
einen Realtek
Netzwerkchip. Das ist
der neueste 10 Gig
Consumer Netzwerkchip von Realtek.
Das ist noch nicht so alt.
Die haben
einen Linux Kernel
Treiber committed.
Irgendeinen Realtek Mitarbeiter.
Das witzige an dem Treiber
ist, dass der Treiber im Prinzip
zu 90% aus Binary besteht.
Also die haben
im Source Code einfach Bytes.
ja die nach vier seiten weise beiz steht in dem source code für den treiber drin
das heißt niemand außer realtex selber es ist ein blob in textform im endeffekt
ja nennt ein blob in in c array syntax c byte array syntax keine sau versteht was
der treiber macht außer realtex selber und der in kernel realtex treiber hat
Probleme mit Virtualisierung.
Du bekommst
in einer VM
nur 5 Gig.
Egal was du machst. Außerhalb
okay, aber in einer VM 5 Gig.
Was du machen kannst ist,
du kannst den offiziellen Realtek-Treiber
von dieser wirklich
sehr hübschen
und dieser wirklich wunderschönen Webseite
von Realtek installieren.
Wenn mir einer die Webseite
ihr schicken würde und sagt max lad dir von damals herunter und installiert ihr
damit ich bedenke was ist das für eine scam seite wie sieht das aus
das china chinesische ministerium für webdesign aber wieder zugeschlagen
aber hier von dieser seite muss man sich den neuesten real tech treiber
herunterladen und selbst kompilieren
und dann hat man das problem nicht mehr dass es in vms langsam ist dafür hast du
dann das Problem, dass das außerhalb von
VMs übelst rumbackt.
Und Realtek jebaitet ihre
User auch richtig hardcore,
weil Realtek schreibt hier
letzte Treiber-Version, released
am 3.7.
Aber
das stimmt gar nicht. Dieser
Treiber ist, wenn du reinguckst, vom Februar.
Die haben einfach diesen
Timestamp hier angepasst, ohne dass sie den
Treiber angepasst haben.
Die haben dich einfach mal verarscht.
So. Und jetzt gibt es
Patches für
den Linux-Kernel-Treiber.
Das heißt nicht mehr für den externen Realtek-Treiber,
sondern jemand hat Patches
gebaut für den Linux-Kernel-Treiber,
für diese Netzwerkkarte.
Die sind aber
noch nicht im Linux-Kernel
selbst verfügbar.
Die sind noch nicht mehr in Network
Next verfügbar. Das heißt,
wir müssen uns
Network Next runterladen,
die Patches aus der Mailing-Liste
applyen,
versuchen das Kernel-Modul zu kompilieren,
irgendwie,
gucken, dass mein Kernel den Scheiß lädt
und dann hoffen,
dass alle Probleme mit der Netzwerkkarte
gefixt sind,
um dann ein halbes Jahr zu warten,
bis man es wirklich benutzen kann,
weil es im Kernel gelandet ist.
Verstanden?
Alles klar?
Also du siehst,
das ist nicht so doll.
Das stimmt. Realtek-Treiber sind nicht dafür bekannt, dass sie die Besten sind.
Realtek hat halt so eine komische Philosophie.
Realtek bringt Chips raus, die super gerne von irgendwelchen Herstellern benutzt werden.
So unter anderem von, in dem Fall jetzt Nassherstellern oder Mini-PC-Herstellern, wo viel Linux draufläuft.
Aber Realtek selber sagt, juckt uns doch nicht, wie gut die Linux-Treiber sind.
Hauptsache der Windows-Treiber funktioniert.
Was juckt mich der scheiß Windows-Treiber?
Soll ich euch nochmal was Witziges erzählen?
Okay, ich kann euch zwei witzige Sachen erzählen.
Das erste ist, bei mir auf der Arbeit gibt es jetzt eine Umstrukturierung.
und ich habe mit meinem Chef geredet, wie da wo umstrukturiert wird und wie das aussieht
und es gibt da wohl den Plan, dass man sagt, man fasst quasi Services oder sagen wir mal Anwendungen letztendlich,
die viele Gemeinsamkeit haben, fasst man zusammen, sodass nicht jedes Team Leute braucht,
die sich mit den gleichen Dingern beschäftigen.
Klingt ja erstmal sinnvoll, aber die wollen für diese Teams keine Betriebssystemtrennung mehr.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, ey Chef, ich würde gern in das Team, was sich um diese und diese Anwendungen schrägstich Services kümmert, dann könnte es sein, dass ich in Zukunft Windows auch mit administrieren muss.
Das Problem dabei ist nur
Dass ich keine Ahnung von Windows hab
Und übelst ausrasten werde, wenn ich Windows administrieren muss
Und ich das auch überhaupt nicht kann
Aber das Gute ist, ich kann mich immer noch drauf rausreden
Mein Arbeitsvertrag, guck hier
Ich bin Senior Linux Engineer
Kommt mir nicht mit Windows
Falsches Aufgabengebiet
Aber es könnte tatsächlich sein
dass ich mich in Zukunft mal auf
ein Windows-System einloggen muss.
Aber wisst ihr, wie ich das dann einfach
machen werde?
Ich mach das dann so, wie die ganzen anderen
Noobs,
die sich bei allem hinstellen,
was sie offiziell nicht
wissen müssen und sagen,
ich weiß nicht, wie das geht.
Ich mach da mal ein Ticket bei den Windows-Leuten
auf oder sowas. Das werde ich dann auch machen.
Dann drücke ich mich um Windows.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
Ich hatte beim alten Arbeitgeber einen, der war geil.
Der hat zu alles und jedem gesagt, wenn einer gesagt hat, hier guckt mal da nach.
Wenn da irgendwas dabei war, was er nicht gut kannte, hat er gesagt, das kann ich nicht machen, da habe ich noch keine Schulung bekommen.
Kennt ihr so Leute?
So nach dem Motto, stellt euch vor, ihr seid eine Linux-Admin.
und jemand sagt zu euch,
übrigens, das kannst du hier im Git-Repo
nachgucken, check dir mal,
check dir mal das und das, check dir mal das und das
Git-Repo aus.
Und dann stellst du dich wirklich hin und sagst,
Git, das kann ich nicht benutzen,
da hatte ich noch keine Schulung zu.
Was ist,
was ist mit den Leuten los, Alter?
Genau, stimmt, stimmt, stimmt.
Schulung reicht ja nicht. Zertifikat.
Also das habe ich nie verstanden, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Weil mal ganz im Ernst.
Wer heutzutage irgendwie, ich sage es mal so, was mit Computer macht.
Der kann sich doch eigentlich sicher sein, dass das, womit er sich jetzt beschäftigt hat,
in spätestens fünf Jahren
ja vielleicht nicht weg ist,
aber sehr viel Neues dazugekommen ist.
Und du kannst dich doch nicht bei jeder Sache
hinter
ich habe keine Schulung bekommen
verstecken, ohne
jeglich irgendwie Eigeninitiative zu zeigen.
Also was heißt kannst du nicht, kannst du
schon, aber
irgendwie ist das nicht meine Philosophie.
Außer bei Windows.
Bei Windows habe ich damit keine Probleme
mich dahinter zu verstecken.
Also ich mache ja fast alles.
Ich sage ja, ich bin, was Gehaltssachen angeht und so, bin ich bestechlich.
Ja, wer mir mehr Gehalt bezahlt, für den mache ich Computerkram, kein Problem.
Aber für Windows müsste er sehr viel Geld bezahlen, dass ich Windows machen würde.
Also wenn jetzt einer zu mir sagt, Max, wir bezahlen dir einfach das Dreifache,
dann würde ich vielleicht sagen, dann mache ich auch Windows.
Für das Doppelte bin ich mir nicht so ganz sicher.
Für das 1,5-fache garantiert nicht.
Ja, es ist ja jetzt schon so.
Ich bin zuständig bei uns für einen internen Service.
Der stellt Grafana und Prometheus bereit.
Was ich auch ganz gut finde, weil ich kenne mich damit ja historisch bedingt ganz brauchbar aus.
Und der besteht aus...
Lass mich mal kurz überlegen.
5 glaube ich
5 Linux Server
Also 2x2
Und eine extra Bastelkiste
Und eine Windows Kiste
Diese Windows Kiste gehört zwar offiziell
Zu meinem Service
Den Service betreue ich seit 2,5 Jahren
Ratet mal wie oft ich auf der Windows Kiste schon eingeloggt war
Oder fragen wir mal umgedreht
Ratet mal ob ich überhaupt
Das Login wüsste
Wie ich mich darauf anzumelden habe
Wie ich überhaupt, nein, noch anders, wie ich überhaupt an ein Login-Fenster käme, um mich da anzuloggen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer.
Ich ignoriere das Ding komplett und bis jetzt juckt es auch keinen.
Also da habe ich gar keinen Plan.
Also wenn ich mich darauf einloggen müsste, würde ich wahrscheinlich erstmal nachgucken,
wir haben so ein Portal für Remote-Zugriff auf Windows-Servern,
ob der da drin ist und dann gucken, ob dann irgendwie ein RDP-Session aufgeht oder sowas in der Richtung.
Aber ansonsten, kein Plastenschimmer. Wirklich absolut kein Plastenschimmer.
Wir schicken ja Redmond zur Schulung. Oh je.
Ich habe schon Microsoft-Schulung gemacht. Ich habe mal eine, oder zwei sogar, zwei Azure-Schulungen gemacht.
Einmal, was war das? Azure Admin 420? Ne, Quatsch.
920, 902, irgendwie sowas.
Diese, einmal diese Basic-Azure-Schulung
und dann noch irgendeine Azure-Schulung.
Und diese Schulung, ganz ehrlich,
hat jemand von euch schon mal Microsoft-Schulung gemacht?
Die sind so langweilig, die sind so dumm.
Microsoft-Schulungen bestehen dadurch,
dass Microsoft dem Trainer ziemlich genau vorgibt,
was er zu zeigen hat.
Und das läuft darauf raus,
Die haben offizielle PowerPoint-Folien von Microsoft.
Die werden durchgeklickt und vorgelesen.
Und dann bekommst du Labs von Microsoft, Übungsaufgaben von Microsoft.
Die sind auch immer die gleichen.
Und diese Übungsaufgaben sind nicht etwa, hier haben sie einen Azure-Test-Account.
Erstellen sie drei VMs, die zonenübergreifend verfügbar sind.
Nein.
Wisst ihr, wie diese Microsoft-Schulungen aussehen?
Wenn das eine Schulung...
Man fragt ja nicht...
Ich bin ernsthaft.
Wisst ihr, wie diese Schulungen aussehen?
Wenn nicht, erkläre ich es euch.
Also weiß es jemand.
Man musste jemand diesen Scheiß auch schon mal machen.
Kann noch mal ein Stückchen hier Melone futtern.
Multiple Choice.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Das wäre ja noch einfacher.
Nee, nee.
Diese Schulung, diese Labs, die sehen folgendermaßen aus. Du hast links dann einen Browser für Azure und rechts hast du eine Anleitung, wie du das Lab korrekt abschließt. Und es ist nicht etwa eine Anleitung, wo drinnen steht, als erstes VMs anlegen, als zweites dran denken, Zonenreplikation.
Nein, das ist eine Anleitung.
Erstens, klicken Sie in das Feld, wo Login steht.
Geben Sie jetzt hier Ihren Benutzernamen ein.
Drücken Sie die Tab-Taste.
Geben Sie jetzt Ihr Passwort ein.
Drücken Sie auf den Login-Button.
Das sind 15 Seiten Anleitung mit wirklich dem kleinsten Furz, der da drin steht.
Und ich... Ey, das ist so...
Das ist wirklich...
Microsoft Schulung, das ist das beschissenste ever.
vielleicht chat ich weiß nicht wie es ist vielleicht hat er jemand von euch
schon mal ein bisschen ein bisschen von ein bisschen was fortgeschrittenes bei
microsoft gemacht von den schulungen ich weiß nicht sind die da besser gibt es
da irgendwie mal gescheit aber das ist das ist grausam also microsoft wirklich
allerletzter krepp
Das stimmt auch öfters was nicht.
Ja, ja.
Die Schulungen sind auch relativ schnell outdated.
Das ist so.
Bis sie das überarbeiten,
kriegen die Trainer dann immer irgendwelche...
Wie nennt man das so?
So einen Guide geschickt.
Und die Trainer müssen dann dabei sagen,
ja übrigens, da steht jetzt nicht mein Login,
sondern, äh...
Hier to Login oder so.
Dann müssen die Trainer dir das immer sagen, wenn sich das geändert hat.
Also Microsoft-Schulungen sind so richtig Bodensatz-Schulungen gewesen.
Richtig dumm.
Also kann ich überhaupt nicht empfehlen.
Moment, was lese ich hier?
Der Kelmore schreibt, bei mir haben sie auf der Arbeit nun den Zugriff von Lienungsmaschinen komplett abgestellt.
und erlaubt wahrscheinlich nur noch Windows durch Conditional Access Policy.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Das ist Windows-Kram.
Aber wenn die Zugriff auf Linux-Kisten abgestellt haben,
was macht ihr denn dann, wenn auf den Linux-Kisten was zu machen ist?
Ja, zum Beispiel gucken, warum irgendeine Anwendung sich nicht so verhält,
wie sie sich verhalten soll oder sowas.
Oder Hilfe, kannst du mal dieses War-File da und da austauschen?
Wir haben einen Bug.
So Admin-Sachen. Wie machen die das dann,
wenn du dich nicht mehr drauf einloggen kannst?
Musst du dann für alles
im Blindflug
einen Ansible-Playbook
machen, obwohl du nicht genau weißt, was du überhaupt machen musst?
Würdest du Set-Servers
für Windows-Hosts machen? Ja, würde ich.
Einfach nur, damit ihr euch
keck-double-unen könnt. Würde ich machen.
Ich würde Set-Servers für Windows-Hosts
machen. Nur zum
Entertainment des Streams.
Nicht, weil ich da Bock drauf hätte, aber nur, weil es wahrscheinlich lustig ist.
Würde ich machen.
Okay, jetzt wurden wir ganz schön sidetracked.
Ich werde jetzt mein Toastbrot und meine restliche Honigmelone hier futtern.
und wahrscheinlich morgen,
je nachdem, wie das so klappt,
mit meinem
Rennen,
ob ich das morgens schon erledigt kriege,
weil wenn ich das morgens nicht erledigt kriege,
dann muss ich das nachmittags irgendwann machen
und danach muss ich mich
mindestens mal eine Stunde gescheit ausruhen.
Hör mir auf
mit dem Microcontroller-Forum.
Leute, die sich zu wichtig nehmen,
hatte ich jetzt die letzten zwei Tage schon genug
auf Twitter.
Brauche ich jetzt nicht auch das Microcontroller-Forum?
Alter, das Microcontroller-Forum.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo die Leute nerviger sind.
Ich glaube, die sind auf unterschiedliche Art nervig.
Im Microcontroller-Forum hast du halt dann immer irgendwie...
Gerhard67 hat mal 8-Bit-Microcontroller mit Assembler programmiert.
und erzähl dir jetzt, dass alles andere scheiße ist, so nach dem Motto.
Und du es eh nicht verdient hast, überhaupt mit Microcontroller was zu machen,
weil du nicht weißt, was die Farben auf den Widerstand bedeuten.
Ja, das sind halt Leute aus dem Microcontroller-Forum.
Kennst du das?
Das Microcontroller-Forum ist ja über alle Grenzen hinaus bekannt,
was seine Freundlichkeit angeht.
Ich habe sogar auf der Arbeit schon Leute gefunden, die das Microcontroller-Forum kannten.
Ach ja, und da wollte ich euch noch was erzählen.
Leute, ich hatte heute Nacht den weirdesten Traum überhaupt.
Und zwar, ich habe Code 4 gespielt.
Ich glaube auf Strike hieß die Map.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht Strike.
Strike ist das mit dem Heli, oder?
Nee, das war Crash mit dem Heli.
Strike mit dieser Straße in der Mitte.
Warte mal.
Code 4 Map Strike.
Nee, das ist die auch nicht.
Wie heißt denn?
Ambush?
Gibt es noch Ambush?
Vielleicht?
Ja, die meine ich.
Warum auch immer.
Übelste Kack-Map.
Übelste Kack-Map. Damals auch nicht gerne gespielt.
Jetzt weiß ich auch warum, weil es da Panzer gibt auf der Map.
Zumindest, ich habe heute Nacht geträumt.
Ich spiele COD 4 auf Ambush.
Multiplayer.
Und ich war übertrieben schlecht.
Das war mir mega peinlich, dass ich so krass sacke in dem Spiel.
Mitgespielt hat Danny Burnage.
Fragt mich nicht, warum Danny Burnage. Keine Ahnung.
Das andere, keine Ahnung, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Und irgendwie, wie ich dann auf der Map da gespielt habe,
da kam ein Panzer von denen, die eigentlich halt sich nicht bewegen.
Und da war das eher Battlefield anstatt Squad 4.
Und ich habe dann mich hinter so einen Stein geduckt.
Und der Typ im Panzer war zu dumm, richtig zu aimen.
und hat mich immer nur mit Splash-Damage
hinter dem Stein erwischt.
Ich bin dann hin und her gesprungen hinter dem Stein
und er hat mich immer nur
mit Splash-Damage erwischt.
Es kam immer permanent dieser
COD-blutige-Augen-Effekt, weil er mich
mit Splash-Damage erwischt hat, aber er hat mich nie erwischt,
weil ich hinter dem Stein geklitscht habe.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt,
dass ich mit drei auf der Tastatur einen RPG habe.
Und dann habe ich,
jetzt wird es komplett wirr,
dann habe ich dreimal mit dem RPG,
der aber eher wie ein Stinger aussieht, aus Battlefield ausgesehen hat, so eine Igla aus Battlefield ausgesehen hat,
habe ich dreimal auf den Panzer geschossen, dann ist der Panzer auf Ambush kaputt gegangen
und dann war das irgendwie wie Battlefield, ich dachte, die Leute springen raus,
dann bin ich da hingerannt, ich habe eine AK-74U dabei, so wie man das in COD 4 hatte
und wollte dann den Typ killen, der aus dem Panzer rauskommt
und da war aber so viel, da war dann so viel, ähm, hier wie auf der Map war das, so viel Staub drumherum, dass ich den nicht gesehen hab,
aber dann hatte ich so einen, wie aus Battlefield, hatte ich so einen Marker drüber, so einen Marker, der wurde dann, der wurde dann quasi im, gespottet, ja, wie in Battlefield 3, gespottet,
Und dann rennt er auf einmal aus dem Staub raus von dem Panzer und verwandelt sich zu Bowser aus Super Mario.
Und dann war es vorbei.
Ne, Moment, dann war er noch nicht vorbei.
Dann war er noch nicht vorbei.
Dann war die Runde vorbei.
Und dann bin ich in der Lobby gelandet.
Und dann bin ich irgendwie drauf gekommen, das war eine gehackte Lobby.
Das war eine gehackte Lobby.
Und COD 4 ist ja schon so alt und COD 4 hat bestimmt wahnsinnig viele Sicherheitslücken.
Und dann hatte ich Angst, dass die Leute mit diesem Bowser-Clitch meinen Rechner infiziert haben.
Und da irgendwas hochladen PSSH und sowas.
Ganz, also super krass weirder Traum.
Keine Ahnung, wie man auf so einen Scheiß kommt.
Vor allem, warum spielt Danny Burnett mit COD 4?
Ich, keine Ahnung.
Das war wirklich, das war komplett, komplett wir.
Aber was man sich nicht im Kopf alle so zurecht macht, ne.
So, Power off.
Komplett random Kram.
Was du schon geschafft hast, ich hab...
Ich habe geschafft, Python relativ statisch zu kompilieren mit Nuitka oder so hieß das.
Hiermit.
Das haben wir kompiliert auf einer ganz, ganz alten Distribution.
Und jetzt läuft unser Python Binary, also Single Binary Executable App,
auf allen Linuxen seit Ubuntu 12.04.
Hier, Spinery ist relativ groß mit 19 MB, aber dafür ist Ridge und NumPy mit dabei.
Und das hat einfach funktioniert.
Die Bildzeiten war schon...
Der war ziemlich detailliert, ja.
Räumst du immer detailliert?
Nee, aber seit ich die Pillen da nehme...
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe jetzt mittlerweile zertifiziert Dachschaden.
Seitdem ich die Pillen nehme, träume ich deutlich öfters so detailliertes Zeug.
und vor allem super krass abgedrehtes Zeug.
Ich träume meistens nichts Schlimmes oder Gefährliches oder so.
Also ich habe auch schon gelesen, dass es manche Leute gibt, die haben halt Albträume.
Was aber eher daran liegt, dass sie zu Albträumen neigen und die halt dadurch verstärkt werden,
wenn man eh schon welche hat.
Aber ich habe meistens so super weirde Träume.
Sowas wie, ich spiele COD 4 oder so.
Ich habe auch letztens mal geträumt, also wie gesagt, seit ich die Pillen nehme,
Das beeinflusst die Träume schon.
Ich habe letztens auch mal geträumt.
Das ist auch witzig.
Ich habe letztens mal geträumt.
Ich bin in First Person.
Oder wie heißt diese Drohne?
Drohne?
POV?
First Person Drone?
First Person View.
Ja.
F-F-Pau-Fee.
F-F-P-V.
Ich habe geträumt.
Ich bin eine First-Person-View-Drohne.
Und da bin ich durch so ein Waldstück geflogen, wie Drohne, ja.
Und hab das auch nur so gesehen, wie eine Kamera das sieht.
Und hatte so richtig so, ich bin durch so eine Reihe Bäume geflogen, als First-Person-View-Drohne.
Und hatte so diesen Kamera-Unschärfe-Effekt.
Weil ich bin irgendwie 900 kmh oder so geflogen
Laut Anzeige
Im Display
Und
Alter was ist denn bescheuert
Warum träumt man jetzt eine First Person View Drohne
Also seit ich die Pillen nehme
Träume ich wirklich ganz abgedrehtes Zeug
Wobei mich das eher erheitert
Als dass mir das Angst macht
Weil wenn ich da aufwache denke ich mir
Was ein Scheiß man
Welche Pillen sind das denn
Das ist
ich will da jetzt nicht jeden Stream was drüber erzählen,
weil ich aus eigener Erfahrung weiß,
es gibt Leute, die
nimmt das selbst
psychisch mit, wenn man über
psychische Erkrankungen redet.
Deswegen will ich das jetzt ein bisschen kurz halten. Ich hab mich da
letztens ja im Stream relativ
lang drüber ausgelassen.
Ich nehm Pillen gegen...
Okay, passt. Alles klar.
Ich nehm das gleiche, by the way.
Wie der 69 Dude.
Das nehme ich, genau das.
Seitdem, muss man sagen, einen positiven Effekt hat es tatsächlich, dieses Zeug.
Das sorgt unter anderem dafür, also das sind Pillen, die werden gegen Depressionen, Angststörungen, Panikstörungen eingesetzt.
Und ich habe ja so ein bisschen Probleme mit Krankheitsangst.
Sodass ich denke, ich habe hier so einen Hirntumor und so ein komisches Zeug.
und das nehme ich dagegen und das hilft.
Das hilft vor allem, wo ich gemerkt habe,
wisst ihr, wo das wirklich hilft?
Bei sozialen Interaktionen.
Ihr wisst, ich scheiße ja immer auf so ziemlich,
also meistens auf zwischenmenschliche Interaktionen,
das ist mir meistens zu anstrengend
und mir gehen die meisten anderen Leuten auch voller Marsch vorbei,
Aber seitdem ich da mir jeden Tag
Cetralin einschmeiß
Bin ich
Voll kontaktfreudig
Ich glaube das wird auch gegen Sozialphobie
Und so eingesetzt, hab ich nicht, aber
Scheint ein bisschen was zu bewirken
Also das ist tatsächlich ein
Ich nenne es mal positiver Nebeneffekt
Ja
Wir haben ja glaube ich schon mal drüber geredet
1.100, Dude.
Du merkst nichts.
Ich merke davon auch nichts.
Wie gesagt, außer ein bisschen das mit dem Träumen.
Dünnschiss habe ich davon gar nicht.
Ja, klar.
Aber was ich dir empfehlen würde,
weil mir es empfohlen würde,
ich habe da keine Ahnung von.
Also zwei Sachen.
Nehmen wir noch ein bisschen weiter,
auch wenn jetzt alles gut ist.
Also auf jeden Fall nicht schnell absetzen.
Das ist nicht empfohlen.
Und die Dinger wirken auch sehr subtil erstmal, weil du die über so einen langen Zeitraum einschleichen musst.
Oder weil es so einen langen Zeitraum dauert, bis die ihre Wirkung aufgebaut haben.
Das dauert ja über vier Wochen, bis die gut wirken.
Und dementsprechend hast du nicht so den Vergleich zwischen heute geht es mir schlecht, heute geht es mir gut.
Sondern es wird langsam besser über vier Wochen.
Das heißt, man denkt gar nicht so sehr, das könnte an den Pillen liegen, aber die können durchaus einen Teil dazu beitragen.
Ja.
Es ist erstaunlich, Leute.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie viele Leute diesen ganzen Krempel nehmen.
Ich habe jetzt ja im Stream schon öfters drüber gesprochen.
Das ist das Gute bei mir.
Also, das stört mich nicht.
Also, das schockt mich nicht.
Das ist mir, also das triggert mich nicht irgendwie oder so. Ich kann da ohne Probleme drüber reden. Also ich weiß ja auch, was für Probleme ich habe und in welchem Bereich, aber ich kann da ohne Probleme drüber reden. Und ich habe auch im Stream schon öfters drüber gesprochen. Auch immer mit dem Hinweis, den ich jetzt auch nochmal geben will.
Viele Leute fühlen sich gerade mit psychischen Erkrankungen sehr alleingelassen und es kann in Deutschland auch manchmal schwierig sein, einen festen Therapieplatz zu finden.
deswegen als Tipp,
wenn ihr wirklich Probleme habt,
egal was es ist,
wenn ihr denkt, ich komme damit nicht mehr klar
oder ich kann da jetzt auch nicht
einen Monat drauf warten,
bis ich mal zu einem Psychiater wegen
Tabletten kann und Therapie
und so dauert eh, was ihr machen könnt,
was richtig was bringt,
was richtig was bringt ist,
guckt, wo es eine psychiatrische
Ambulanz bei euch gibt.
Die muss es in jedem,
es gibt mindestens eine,
hier gibt es mehrere, die zuständig
ist für euren
Bereich. Da könnt ihr hingehen. Da könnt
ihr sogar ohne Überweisung hingehen.
Da guckt ihr einfach, wann die aufmachen und setzt
euch morgens hin. Ich persönlich
hab, ich war zweimal da, ich hab damit
nur gute Erfahrungen gemacht. Es ist
überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Ich hatte auch Bedenken, da hinzugehen,
weil Psychiatrie, denkst du, die stecken dich gleich in die
Zwangsjacke und lassen dich nie wieder
raus. Kompletter Blödsinn. Darf man in
Deutschland gar nicht, so ohne weiteres.
Mach das. Also wenn ihr da...
Na doch, doch. Das ist ja
eine Ambulanz. Das ist genau dafür gedacht.
Du kannst dich da morgens hinsetzen
und sagen, ich komm nicht
mehr klar. Ich brauch Hilfe.
So. Und
die geben dir dann auch kurzfristig
zur Überbrückung
schon mal Medikamente und reden mit dir.
Die sind genau für solche Akutfälle da.
Müsst ihr mal
gucken bei euch, wenn ihr da Probleme habt. Deswegen,
Das wollte ich jetzt an der Stelle nochmal sagen, weil viele Leute mit Depressionen, Angststörungen, Panikstörungen oder einfach psychischen Erkrankungen an sich, die haben immer das Gefühl, die stehen da komplett allein da und wissen manchmal nicht, was sie machen sollen.
Ja, und dazu halt einmal, wie gesagt, man steht nicht allein da, es ist, vieles dieser Sachen ist super viel schon bekannt, analysiert und sonst was.
Und wenn ihr mit jemandem drüber redet, wird er euch sagen, eure Symptome fast wie aus dem Lehrbuch, ihr seid da nicht alleine und ihr müsst es auch nicht alleine mit euch ausmachen.
Ihr könnt zu so einer Ambulanz gehen, das ist kein Problem. Relativ schnell kriegt man auch ein Erstgespräch, was Psychologen angeht. Aber so ein Besuch bei einer psychiatrischen Ambulanz, und die gibt es, die muss es für jeden Bereich geben, guckt, wer für euch zuständig ist, kann ich wirklich nur empfehlen.
Die reden mit euch, geben euch erstmal akut auch Medikamente, die für euch passen, so dass ihr erstmal wieder klarkommt, dass ihr erstmal wieder ein bisschen runterkommen könnt und normal wieder denken könnt. Also das kann ich wirklich, wenn ihr da Probleme habt, macht das.
nicht nur aussitzen.
Weil aussitzen, habe ich auch schon öfters gesagt,
als, ähm, Moment.
Das habe ich auch schon öfters gezeigt.
Wenn man psychische Probleme nur aussitzt,
dann ist das wie Traktor-Pulling.
Guck mal.
Traktor-Pulling ist,
ist so ein Ami-Sport.
Das sind super krass aufgemotzte
Traktoren, sollen das sein.
Und damit geht es darum,
möglichst viel Erde,
also, da muss ich es ansehen,
guck mal, hier ist so ein Flug.
Die haben so einen Flug hier hinten
und der Flug, der
schabt quasi Erde vor sich her.
Das heißt, mit jedem Meter,
den der Traktor vorwärts fährt,
steigt der
Berg an Erde, den er hinter sich herzieht.
Ja, und irgendwann,
ihr seht es ja hier, ne? Und irgendwann
ist dieser Berg so groß,
dass er
nicht mehr weiterfahren kann, weil er
keine Power mehr hat.
So ist das bei psychischen Erkrankungen, wenn ihr die
einfach nur Augen zu und durch aussitzt.
Das ist wie mentales
Ich glaube, mein Browser ist gecrashed.
Das ist wie mentales Tractor Pulling.
wie gesagt, kann euch nur empfehlen, wenn es akut ist, geht in die Ambulanz.
Wir haben doch alles schon mal gesehen.
Und by the way, auch noch was, wenn ihr was sucht,
ihr könnt bei Online-Portalen gucken nach Psychiatern mit Videosprechstunde,
nach Psychologen mit Videosprechstunde.
Da könnt ihr nämlich ganz deutschlandweit gucken.
Da gibt es immer mal wieder Termine.
oder was auch geht, gerade zu einem Psychiater muss man ja nicht oft,
da geht es ja meistens nur darum, ab und zu mal checken, wie es mit Medikamenten läuft.
Das kann man auch selbst bezahlen.
Das kostet dann so 150, 160 Euro pro halbe Stunde bis 50 Minuten geht das.
Und muss man nicht oft machen, kriegt man aber schnell einen Termin.
Also es gibt Möglichkeiten auf jeden Fall.
Aber wenn es gar nicht geht, in die Ambulanz gehen.
So
Das stimmt, das stimmt
Viele Leute machen mentales Traktor Pulling
Ja und was ich eigentlich sagen wollte
Nur um diesen Disclaimer jetzt vorher zu schicken
Ich
Hab mich selbst gewundert, weil ich ja öfters im Stream schon drüber gesprochen hab
Wie viele Leute
Ähnliche Probleme haben
Damit geht halt keiner hausieren irgendwie
Und sagt, oh ja Leute, ich hab so nicht mal alle psychische Probleme
Macht ja keiner so wirklich
Aber wenn man mit den Leuten drüber redet, ich habe auf der Arbeit schon mit mindestens drei Leuten drüber gesprochen, die auch ähnliche Probleme hatten.
Und hier, wenn ich im Stream drüber rede, findet sich jeden Stream auch wieder Leute, die sagen, ja, hatte ähnliche Probleme, nehme ähnliche Sachen.
Man glaubt gar nicht, wie viele Leute psychische Probleme haben.
Man sieht es denen ja auch nicht an.
Also.
Ja, das finde ich auch fatal.
Das finde ich wirklich fatal, dass zur Zeit die Politik versucht, gerade das einzusparen, weil ich denke nicht, gerade mal langfristig gedacht, führt das zum genauen Gegenteil.
Wenn du da einsparst, werden die Leute halt richtig krank und sind zu gar nichts mehr zu gebrauchen.
Also langfristig ist das, glaube ich, der schlechteste Move, den man machen kann, das einzusparen.
Wirklich mit Abstand der schlechteste Move.
Das ist richtig, das ist richtiger
Boomer-Move. Keine Ahnung, das ist richtig Low-IQ-Move,
das einzusparen. Das bringt vielleicht
initial erstmal ein paar Euro
in der Kasse.
Aber auf lange Sicht
bringt das gar nichts. Das macht es eher noch schlimmer.
Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß.
Es gibt viele
solche Substanzen, die
auch Tiere kriegen. Beispielsweise
es gibt für Katzen, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
wie es heißt, es gibt so
eine, also
wird für Menschen und Katzen benutzt, bei Katzen
wird es benutzt, wenn die super aufgeregt sind
in die Tierklinik oder zum Tierarzt
oder da noch Weile bleiben müssen
teilweise, dann kriegen die sowas, das beruhigt die
das funktioniert bei Tieren wie bei Menschen
also insgesamt
gibt es viel mehr Leute als man
denkt, die
Probleme haben, psychischer Natur
Ihr könnt davon ausgehen, wenn ihr im Bus oder in der S-Bahn oder im Zug sitzt, ein Viertel der Leute um euch drum herum hat wahrscheinlich gerade Probleme oder hatte schon mal Probleme.
Gut, dann habe ich das auch nochmal angesprochen
Mir ist das immer wichtig
Da auch zu sagen, dass man da
Möglichkeiten hat
Weil ich weiß, wie es sich dann anfühlt, wenn man denkt
Ey
Man kommt da alleine nicht klar und es gibt ja keine Möglichkeiten
Man neigt ja auch immer dazu, das zu katastrophisieren
Im Kopf
Gerade wenn man so Probleme hat
Ne, also Ambulanz ohne Scheiß kann ich euch empfehlen.
Wenn ihr Probleme habt, guckt jetzt einfach bei Google nach, wo es eine psychiatrische Ambulanz gibt.
Und schaut, wann die aufmachen, setzt euch dahin.
Ihr könnt euch eine Überweisung holen vom Hausarzt, aber ihr braucht keine Überweisung.
Ihr könnt natürlich vorher mal anrufen oder so.
Und meine Erfahrung ist, die sind echt nett gewesen.
Die wissen, wie man mit Leuten umgeht.
Und die haben, gerade Leute, die in so einem Krankenhaus, das ist ja im Endeffekt ein Krankenhaus, ja, arbeiten, die haben auch wirklich alles schon mal gesehen.
Also, die kannst du mit nichts mehr schocken.
Da könnt ihr das Abgedrehteste, Abartigste haben, die sind nicht mehr geschockt.
Du kannst die Leute da nicht mehr schocken.
So, Chat, wir sehen uns morgen, ich futter jetzt noch schnell was.
Nein, es ist keine LG.
Gerade ist dazu gekommen, ich kann teilweise zustimmen.
Dann ist doch gut.
Freut mich, dass du immerhin teilweise zustimmen kannst.
Ähm.
Ich habe keine LG.
Ich habe eine Mitsubishi-Klimaanlage.
Gut, dann macht es jetzt gut, Leute.
Bis morgen. Wahrscheinlich.
See you.